ừ ừ
anh alo
anh
alo chào các bạn ạ
cách nấu Zalo nóng
Các bạn thấy màn hình mình chưa ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ
Ok
hôm nay thì các bạn thấy thì mình để
tiêu đề đó kẹo hôm nay sẽ là kiểm tra
một loạt các đồ án của từng nhóm để mà
xem là ở tiến độ từng nhóm đang đến đâu
sẽ vào nhóm nào phù hợp để bảo vệ đồ án
một rồi A đồ ăn bớt một đời một rồi sẽ
có 2 đợt ý nghĩa như thế chưa chưa biết
là sẽ có được Sao không nhấc lại có hai
đã đồng loạt thì
thì mình phải thực ra là mình có kiểm
tra trước Tết rồi nhưng mà sau Tết này
không biết các bạn đã thêm thôi các bạn
đập đi thăm bạn từ đâu không biết được
nên là bây giờ Nói chung à Bây giờ là
gần như hôm nay buổi chốt đi mình sẽ
mình sẽ đánh giá qua tất cả các nhóm có
bởi vì có một vài nhóm còn là còn mới
ghép lại nữa Tự nhiên thành hiểu sao tự
nhiên còn kiểu ghép lại nữa rồi vì có
một vài thành viên tự nhiên nghị đề xuất
ra thì như mình đã tôi nói cái khó tránh
khỏi và thường Ế là là sẽ luôn là rơi
rụng và vào lúc mới mới tạo nhóm thì các
bạn chưa có gắn bó lắm các bạn sẽ rơi
rụng hoặc là lúc mà cận kề như này thì
các bạn sẽ rơi rụng với các bạn cảm thấy
có đầy áp lực các những thứ thì các bạn
sẽ sử dụng thì thế bởi vì cái này nó
không nó không bị ép buộc giống như là
một cái bằng cấp gì đó dẫn trường một
cái gì đó các bạn đang theo đuổi là
Ừ nhưng mà
Ừ cái mà Ngoài ra thì mình thấy có rất
nhiều nhóm
nó giá là ổi các bạn có thể thấy nhớ lúc
mình để mô Có phải ngọn rất ngầu nữa xỉn
rồi thì cái nhóm đấy mình cảm thấy rất
là trình vọng em sẽ mình triển vọng đó
sẽ là đồng nghiệp của mình thương lại
lại chẳng hạn thì mình hi vọng à
à Hôm nay mình sẽ phải ít nhất à cũng
phải được 20 nhóm đi đấy ít nhất trí
nhất được 20 nhóm đủ để bảo vệ đời một
sau đó thì mình sẽ có
mình mình sẽ có buổi bỏ vết thương sau
đó nhạ Nói chung là toàn bộ những cái
kiến thức dậy mình đã truyền đạt tương
đối tương đối ổn để mà làm cái đón web
cơ bản rồi ông ạ Nhưng mà trước hết thì
ạ Ở mình đến tâm sự trước hay kiểm tra
trước nhỉ Nếu chọn nào heo mấy ông cứ
tâm sự ở ở tre trước đi rồi thì à
đến cuối buổi cuối giờ mình tâm sự
khi được còn bây giờ mình cứ kiểm tra
sớm nha
em kiểm tra và đánh giá trước nóng
ừ ừ
Anh ơi thế Tôi sẽ mở cái này để mà để mà
phù hết code mới nhất của mấy ông về tới
sáng
à à
a fairly g.đ
I really simeone bị phát đi
à mà không hồ Sao lại tắt máy đi vì cái
này à Tôi đang mở Cốt trên công ty với
ông đọc mà ông xóa nó không hiểu gì
không ạ
ừ ừ
ở chỗ này 25 - 2 cái này nữa là có hai
23 nhóm đấy nhớ 23 nhóm đã có cốt Còn
mấy nhóm khác thì chưa
cha mẹ về kéo hết toàn bộ cốt về này cho
tôi inbox lại tao đây này
có bao nhiêu nhóm khi còn chưa có đi Báo
lỗi đã ta bay Vân Cơ
à à
Ừ tôi vẫn chưa hình dung là nên phát lì
xì gì mấy ông cơ à
Ê hồi trước thì tôi còn nghĩ việc là ờ
cốt một cái đoạn mà
a court 1 lời bạn có ông làm mà vào
YouTube Campuchia cách đây tầm 35 dễ
thấy tối thường hay còn đăng mấy cái
kiểu
à À tôi đang mấy cái
em bị nó bảo bị lag không biết mày không
có thấy tôi đang chuẩn bị nát không
ờ ờ thì thôi đấy tôi thường hay làm mấy
cái kiểu livestream để mà kiểu Nếu bình
luận cái gì thì sẽ hiển thị cái bình
luận đấy Ở lên cái livestream của tôi
thấy nó khá hay gửi tăng độ tương tác
Ừ nếu không hiểu mà đúng không nhé thì
nó sẽ kiểu khuyến khích người khác thân
tác đấy cũng hay mà
ừ ừ
cài
đặt đậu nổi tiếng nhất
ở thì
khi kéo cốt này có vẻ về không được này
đang đợi đấy Tại sao bị lỗi nhà ở
a people found đ ở nhóm mày Như bai19a
Ừ
để cancel
ừ
à nó cả hôm trước có một sinh viên của
tôi cũng bảo một cái ý rất là hay Tôi
mời nhắn tin với người ta nhưng mà có vẻ
ra không chạy vọng lắm đó là ở
sinh viên của tôi bảo là ờ ờ
Ừ vậy Sao anh không dùng vệt cái Tu là
để mà
ờ ờ
cái tôi nhỉ
đi xe đạp này hay
cả hai lần xin cho
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ cái tool để mà khi khi mà khi mà tôi
nói tôi cốt như thế nào thì có bạn xem
được luôn cái cốt của tôi đang Cốt nó có
cái có hai ở bên VP tôm thì nó sẽ là có
khái niệm là courtney khá là ngon có
bixby này khi cái này tiện cực Và thậm
chí còn phù hợp để nó dậy online nữa bởi
vì nó bởi vì nó còn là kiểu nó con
thế này nó phù hợp cho cả tít cho anh Sư
đoàn này Đấy nó còn có cả nút bấm là bắt
buộc các bạn phải theo dõi tôi cơ hãy
for a giờ từ follow me How far you live
từ ra tôi sẽ không dừng này nhưng em
chưa Nó còn tiện như thế nó còn kéo cho
các bạn xem được không phải là một cái
file mà tôi đang cốt giờ mà cả và sửa
tôi nhảy sang file khác nhanh quá mà các
bạn chưa kịp xem file cũ đúng không Thì
hôm nay thế nữa màn hình của tôi có thể
cũng bé cho các bạn vẫn vân vân hoa các
bạn ngồi nhắn thôi cốt cũng chán thì các
bạn sẽ tự chủ động mở cái cốt của tôi
lên code mà tôi đang cốt đấy để các bạn
xem sẽ mới hiểu là cái đoạn nói gì và
tiện hỏi hơn tôi thấy cái đấy rất là hay
đúng không nghe phải ra thú vị nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà cái thứ nhất là đấy nhưng mất
tiền thôi này có bạn miễn phí thì bạn
thấy cái ảnh nào ít người mà mất tiền
thì dành cho nhiều người hơn cái này có
mi này vào thêm một cái nữa tôi tôi tôi
thấy là có một cái á
Anh ở bristol nhạc
Tôi nhớ cái gì nhỉ Lại cốt xe
của
hai ở cốt cái gì đó nữa nó nguồn chuyên
bị có vấn đề đúng không
à à
cho
tôi thế là nguồn chim có vẻ không ổn
định nó à
cho mấy bạn đang xem có ổn định
cha
[âm nhạc]
mẹ mày ông đang xem chuyên muốn đánh ông
để thử tắt hết những cái thiết bị khác
rồi thì
ok Ờ đúng rồi Bên vs tốt cũng có ghét
cốc không có đấy Ờ
thì thì cái á
khi thấy tôi hôm trước là xem thì tôi đã
kiểu dùng mail của Adu để mà để mà kiểu
nhắn tin nó họ là kiểu Tôi đang dạy
online thì cho hồ thể xin các thử được
không Họ nói bà lại là với điều kiện hả
bạn phải gửi lại là tôi cái kiểm chứng
nhận kiểu giấy tờ đó xác nhận là bạn
đang đang dạy ở cho cái chuông ở đó rất
tiếc là bây giờ tôi không thể ở trường
học nữa anh Hiền cái cái cái điều đấy
không làm được rồi đăng tiếp cái khổ
trước cho tôi dậy ở trường cũ rồi tao
vẫn sẽ có thể làm sao đây
3ngày cho tôi phải tìm một cái thay thế
tôi nghĩa tôi vẫn sẽ tìm được người ta
sẽ sớm thôi để mà dạy cho mấy ông chứ về
sau tôi dậy mấy ông sang bên tao leo thì
Cốt nó sẽ dai hơn nữa bạn nhiều file hơn
nữa nên thành ra là kiểu nó kiểu Nếu mà
tôi mình nhận sang file mới nhanh quá
phải cũ của mấy ông chưa kịp xem thì
đúng là mấy ông dễ kiểu không không
không bắt kịp được Nếu không hiểu thì
thôi cái kiểu thế nên là tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ
bắt buộc phải tìm một phần mềm nào đó
hoặc hoặc là tôi đang nghĩ có cái chiêu
này nhưng mà không không biết được và có
làm được như thế không đó là ờ
cho tôi cứ mỗi lần tôi bấm lưu lại file
thì nó sẽ có tự động con nít để lên kít
để mấy ông mấy ông cu về để xem thì ra
là nó sẽ bị ngược điểu nó sẽ không kiểu
Xem trực tiếp liên tục liên tục được
đúng không ạ Không phải về nữa rồi các
từ thứ
mày không hiểu thì thôi Không thì chắc
là sẽ xây kiểu à
Ừ cái kiểu như thế Cái con mít kia cho
là có thể làm được tự động kiểu cư cứ
lưu lại thì tự động con nít cũng có một
cách mà nó không ạ ạ
anh bởi vì mấy Là ngày thì nó có nhược
điểm này nhá Mấy cái hàng mà miễn phí
như này rất là nó sẽ là kiểu
sẽ Kiều không xe cốc chỉ cho một lượng
người xem nhất định thôi chứ không xem
kiểu trực tiếp theo kiểu 52 tượng thứ
100 ông cùng một lúc được có sau khi bảo
vệ đồ án này thì nói chung là tấm tháng
3 đi cứ cho thằng Ba ít ít nhất chậm
nhất đến tháng 3 thì mình sẽ dậy xanh Ok
này mvc là sao nó nhảy sang lao em ạ ạ
vì
tim em hai người mà giờ không liên lạc
được ngày kia thì em đánh luôn đúng bây
giờ Đành phải chấp nhận thế thôi Bây giờ
còn chưa nhóm gì nữa đúng hạn bây giờ
dàng chấp nhận là kiểu ông và đang làm
phần nào mà kiểu ông kia nghị thì thôi
11 là kiêm nốt phần của ông kia đúng ạ
là thực ra là cái khái niệm ở đây để
mình cho các bạn hiểu rõ quen với việc
làm việc theo nhóm phẩm chứa đi làm công
ty cũng thế Thật đi làm công ty rồi nhá
đi làm công ty các bạn sẽ gặp người này
kia và cũng sẽ kiểu đang làm việc dở vẫn
tin vào đó rồi tự như kiến nghỉ việc thì
các bạn một là các bạn gánh hay là sẽ có
người khác gánh hộ các bạn các bạn nhưng
mà cũng sẽ khó chịu vân vân chúng mình
đang dạy
Ừ mình đang muốn để cho các bạn thấy
thực tế nhất khi đi làm đúng như thế nào
không ạ nghĩa ở mọi thứ được không như
xuyên sẽ suôn sẻ như các bạn mong muốn
hoặc sẽ gặp rất nhiều thành phần có
người rõ mình có người làm hết mà chẳng
làm gì cả Có người thì chả làm gì cả
thật mất tăm mất tích không ạ nhưng Cái
quan trọng là nó cũng sẽ khác là nó
không ảnh hưởng đến các bạn theo kiểu
lại các bạn không bị trừ lương các bạn
không bị gì cả chả cua đương nhiên việc
các bạn có thể nặng hơn nhưng mà người
ta sẽ đánh giá cao các bạn hơn các bạn
sẽ được tăng lương Nếu các bạn làm kiêm
phần người ra nữa vân vân vân đúng không
ạ Đấy thì
Vì thế nên là mình nghĩ là nó cũng có ưu
và nhược thôi thực tế các bạn sẽ không
được trọn đồng nghiệp Ý mình nhấn mạnh
nó là như thế không ạ Có không chọn đồng
nghiệp gì cả nên là thế nên là các bạn
gặp được nhiều đối tượng đấy thì các bạn
phải quen dần đi không ạ Đi học đại học
để các bạn
gần sát với thức đấy nhất mà đông ạ
Em ở chỗ nào Mình sẽ tìm hiểu về một
trong những cái này và mình sẽ thử các
bạn sang Nga hôm trước này đây mình mail
cho thằng Cốc Cốc cho ghe rồi này nhưng
mà nó bảo là cần có giấy giấy tờ xác
nhận là mình đang dậy gì đó thôi Mình
không trả lời nữa
chứ không đi Tối nay tôi đã định thử để
mua mày không xem luôn đấy
à à
vì vậy tận 1.500 phải thay đổi Sợ thế
nóng làm cái gì mà khiếp thế Ok đây mình
sẽ inbox lại là giờ bay sau đó thì thử
thừa
ở tủ xem kiểm tra từng nhóm nhé
Không biết mấy ông nãy rồi có theo Kitô
mỉ
vẫn theo kịp đúng không ạ
ở tại mày nhiều lúc thấy béo Im lặng quá
rồi chẳng biết rồi nha
Ê mày đang đang 50 ông mà không nghe
được chưa chui một định alo
U50 một tích thay đổi ý
có ai mà mình sẽ bóp hết toàn bộ tao bây
giờ nhá
em ở làm như khi tôi làm việc thì sẽ là
tôi sẽ bờ tất cả mọi người xung quanh à
Ừ ông vẫn thử
có một nhóm đang bị sai này là cái á
Ừ
nó lỗi để còn hóa đơn cái này hình như
là do là khoáng ngoại nó hình như là bạn
lại Insert xong rồi bạn mới nối khóa
ngoài vậy nên nó lỗi gì đó
từ ngày 17 ngày tạm xóa cái phần Xuân
thêm này ra được
chỉ có vài nhóm chưa có file setup ai
này à
ừ ừ
à à
có
gì đó bạn kia cho chưa quen linh vật ở
cánh chim của mình nói nhưng vật hơi tía
số 7
mình sẽ inbox riêng lại cái
nhóm 17A
ừ ừ
em bị lỗi
Em mới phát ý
à Thế bây giờ đã xóa cái gì nhỉ à
It is Pretty Ok này số tạo này đi à
Ừ ok ok rồi Em có được xong hết rồi bé
đầu tiên thì mình sẽ lướt qua một loạt
hết do diện các thứ lạnh lỡ lại cho mọi
người xem xem giao diện xem trông như
thế nào Sau đó thì mình sẽ đánh giá việc
là tính năng rất nhiều thứ về ổn chưa nó
ạ ạ
anh
Linh không không tôi bởi vì a mic của
tôi nó nhận đi sợ ở các bạn là bị
bị sao mà tôi có phải tắt tiếng đấy ạ
anh
không nên gọi là anh đi đừng gọi thấy sợ
à
xe khách hàng chưa nhất
thế này nằm ở file con ếch này đúng
không
có con ếch
một
cách hàm
à à
vợ
chồng hấp dẫn nha Nhưng mà như tôi đã
nói Thực ra các bạn không nên bán đồ ăn
đồ uống rồi qua web
bởi vì thời gian nó khá lằng nhằng liên
quan đến hạn đã từng thử nữa
ạ Bây giờ mẹ em còn duyệt đơn nữa mình
không biết bao giờ rồi khách rồi mới
được ăn
ờ ờ
vì trông cũng phải chị mà nó ngon
nữ ca sĩ này bị tất cả tên người nhận từ
điển là thứ thì sao
ở
đây ngoài địa chỉ thật của tôi hiện tại
đâu nha
ca nhạc không thông báo anh thành công
nghĩa không biết là có bên shop có gì
được chưa đăng nhập
Nếu bạn chưa có tài khoản Ok điền để tôi
chưa là tôi chưa bỏ qua các bạn làm cái
biết nhé tạm bỏ qua đã thì đương nhiên
là hôm bảo vệ đoán thì tôi sẽ yêu cầu
các bạn phải hoa Tết
là tôi sẽ hỏi và cái ngoan videsh còn
đưa con nhờ Nói chung là cứ điện được
đúng hết chị đã xem được không nha thể
bà này
bí mật khẩu ngắn quá
Tôi có 123 Tại sao nó
không có rồi ra 4 nhé không ngắn quá cho
các cụ mày đi à
anh lại phải qua đây vẫn Âm Nhạc à
ok à
xin
lỗi Đúng không gửi Thế trưa à
à à
Ừ mẹ lỗi không Ok Em thử đăng nhập lại
Ừ Ok sang bên là admin mà
I am in không thể amin là gì đoán thử
thách vào nhà
em dạo này có 2 file con nách không nên
bọn nên một phải con ếch rồi được
ba ngày sau phải chuyển ở Hà Nội lấy về
sau thì các bạn sang bên đoán hay các
bạn sẽ được zậy là Minh dễ có 1 file
file config với cấu hình các bạn chỉ cần
sửa các file cấu hình để rất là mọi chỗ
khác mà phải dạy giống như thế vừa rồi
liên quan cấu hình tao bây giờ nó ngoại
các bạn không có việc các kiểu cũng mỗi
lần các bạn muốn thay đổi của chi tiết
nhỏ gì đó là các bạn sẽ phải sửa rất
nhiều file Không nên như thế ngoại các
bạn phải tư duy lập trình đó là làm một
cái sản phẩm mà mình phải sửa lâu dài
phải bỏ thì phải nâng cấp lâu dài chứ
không nên chuyện mà cậu làm xong cho có
rồi thôi ông ạ thì toàn bộ những cái gì
mà các bạn nghĩ về sau sẽ thay đổi đóng
ngoặc sẽ phải thay đổi nâng cấp hay gì
đó thì các bạn Vậy phải làm sao cho Cốt
nó dễ hiểu này và dễ sửa cái đón Hay
mình sẽ dậy rất sâu về cái đấy bởi vì
đoán một thì các bạn biết về lập trình
biết qua rồi với vòng lặp nội dung biết
tiếp theo biết các em biết lập trình rồi
còn đón Hay thì mình sẽ dậy sâu hơn về
tư duy của lập trình viên phải như nào
và à cốt sao cho nó có khoa học lôgic
này thế đồ ăn 1 thì phù hợp cho các bạn
kiểu biết quan thì nó bảo lập trình của
đồ ăn hay mới thật sự là để mà đào tạo
nghề các bạn để các bạn như kiểu có thể
treo được ngày này và các bạn thấy phù
hợp với ngành này thì để đồ ăn hay đoán
bột thì các bạn có thể ai cũng làm được
đòi một mình khẳng định như thế Kể cả
không phải dân công nghệ còn đồ ăn hay
thì những bạn nào dân công nghệ những
bạn là người có tư duy phù hợp với dân
công nghệ hiểu có cái gọi là không khả
năng khiếu đâu mình chỉ ra kèo kiểu dạng
mà từ từ gì suy nghĩ được nhưng một cái
dẫn công nghệ nghĩ ra được chỗ ngồi tính
toán được những cái đấy thì sẽ phù hợp
nhanh này hơn và kiên trì được Kiểu càng
họ cảm thấy hay ấy chứ bởi vì đồ ăn hay
nó sẽ rất là rộng nó sẽ kéo rất là nhiều
nó khá là quá tải của nhiều không nên là
tủ lạnh đấy mình nói qua như thế hôm nay
tâm sự mà phải nó qua trước những cái
đấy mẹ Chào mấy ông cũng vỡ mộng rừng đi
tìm đâu thấy đồ ăn bột dại quá mấy ông
đĩa đồ ăn hay nó dễ như thế đi không đón
hay nói cái gì đó không phải là web nâng
cao nữa đó là web chim sâu việc gì đó
rồi
xe môtô trong mạng
tại trang ah
Ừ anh nhớ bạn ấy đang gái biết rồi
khi nghe tôi vào thẳng database em út
đấy
để mật khẩu như thế nào
vì nó có sữa luôn cốt cũng được nó in
vừa sex
Em
định lí1 hiện được à
bí đỏ rồi
quản lý sản phẩm quản lý đơn hàng
về quản lý sản phẩm hiển thị mô tả Đà
Nẵng
cố gắng mô tả hơi dài
các bạn này có các độ uống chỗ nhìn thị
ra hết rồi lấy luôn không có phân trang
ra lại hơi bị nhược điểm ông ạ bởi vì
sao dài quá bạn này các bạn đấy nên Tách
cái này ra thành menu con nữa là kiểu
cái loại sản phẩm nào loại sản phẩm này
thì ra hết được đây
hơn thì phù hợp hơn đây mình xem lại tao
bây bạn đầy thiết kế đã đây có phân ra
ba loại thế chắc cũng có loại sản phẩm
này có thể loại này các bạn này quy
thẳng luôn là chỉ có 3 thể loại thôi nên
là không có quản lý thể loại hoặc là đây
à bây giờ chắc là ăn mini không phải
Superman rồi còn thể loại Nhưng mà
ờ ờ
Ừ
nhưng mà mình lên kiểu có cái chụp
quét ở dưới này không ạ xong rồi kéo cái
gì có những thể loại nhỏ nhỏ đây sao bấm
vào anh chị hết ra thì mình nghĩ là cái
để nó ổn hơn không ạ
để thêm sản phẩm cái này nhược điểm mà
mình đã từng nói Nếu mà như thế này thì
bấm bấm là đây có
Khi
bữa nay đấy phải quay lại trang chủ cái
cần nhất thứ hai là không nên để làm mất
Thay máy ngu như mày không ạ Người ta lỡ
bấm nhầm gì đó người ta muốn quay lại
người ta rất khi người ta bấm lại cái
này hạn chế cho người dùng bấm nút quay
lại mà phải có ăn cái cái thẻ để bấm
quay lại này hoặc nói chung luôn hiển
thị menu ở đây nó đôi khi nó còn khái
niệm cả grad-cam nữa nếu các bạn biết
Fresh from kìa
Ừ thì nó là kiểu kẻ gọi là phân cấp con
của khi mà trò đến kể chị mục vào đó thì
rõ ràng trang cho vụ này vào thằng này
đây Thằng con nữa này và thằng con này
là nó hiển thị ra như thế này để các bạn
có thể quay lại trước đấy có thể hiểu là
mình đang ở nhà nhà không ạ thì mình nên
làm thế trải nghiệm người dùng tốt hơn
Ừ Ok bạn này Nói chung là làm được cũng
giao diện để chị ngồi đúng không ạ
ở Đà Nẵng được duyệt đơn chưa được duyệt
cái này thì các bạn cũng như mình vừa
nói thì các bạn nên hiển thị ra hai cái
mục ở đây là tất cả đơn này đang chưa
được duyệt đơn đã được duyệt Tuy bấm vào
tiện và có phân tranh này ổn hơn trước
đấy không có phân trang thì và tìm kiếm
Anh không biết nên gợi ý luôn ở đây
không phải võ Tìm kiếm nữa ở đây người
ta nhìn thấy người biết tìm kiếm rồi Các
bạn nên ghi rõ đây là
tìm theo mã
mã hóa đơn hay mã khách hàng hoặc không
ạ mã khách hàng và cũng không Dạ không
hiểu mà khách hàng lắm số điện thoại
khách hàng để phù hợp hơn thì mình theo
cái gì đó để cho dễ tin không ạ Cái
đôi kỵ đôi khi là tìm cho các thời gian
được
ừ ừ
cơ bản thì có bạn nên tìm cho mình cái
đấy à
ờ ờ sửa thừa không đến trà sữa tương tự
khách hàng lắm nhà thôi mình đồ ăn một
mình chỉ đầy đủ thì nó thêm sửa xóa được
Chắc đây admin hỏi Super Bean này nói ít
quyền hơn ok nhóm này ra bảo vệ rồi đón
một rồi giờ mình sẽ đổi sang
đợt à nhóm thứ hai a
chi tiết tìm em lâu hãy cho gọi liên
quan gửi mail rồi
à à
khi sex
ờ ờ ờ
[âm nhạc]
Em
hôm nay có khách rồi nha anh có xóa chó
sủa nhiều
anh ở đây bạn này Thống nhất là để trong
thư mục admin cũng được con ếch này hay
này à
cho nó
anh nhìn FPT Shop
kể về giao diện hơi bị vỡ một tí rồi tôi
run lên Nhưng không sao không chặn
cho tôi rung lên vỡ hả không do bạn này
kéo để cố định cái chiều chiều cao nó
thì ra nó bị tràn ra
à à
anh đăng ký cái này đấy như mình đã nói
nó nhảy sang Hạ Trắng nhé Xong rồi không
có quay lại những trải nghiệm phải kém
tí Ờ
Ừ Ok Chú đăng ký
điền đầy đủ thông tin đăng ký sao ạ
khi sex
i10 số ngày 16 mà
Ừ Rồi tắt hẳn 3D Christmas song không ạ
anh không ạ công anh cho số điện thoại
cho không hợp lệ này à
các clip
mình có thể ghi đè lên phong trần diện
ngay
check
cho get ơn đã Chu luôn ở trung Ai là
được
thêm một cách một cách thôi còn nhiều
cách ạ
à à
khi sex
hôm nay hạn chế nước Anh là Việt cái anh
nhé
khi cha copy về đấy
a
Cho tôi xem tư vấn đề về có đăng ký
Thành Công Trứ đi lễ hay nhận đăng nhà
thứ lại hơi say say
an Đăng ký gọi điện cho anh công ngoại
cũng không thông báo gì cả kể tớ thử này
xem khách hàng một
các bạn nên có sẵn tài khoản Nói chung
là hôm bảo vệ thử mình sẽ nói qua những
cái từ các bạn cần chuẩn bị cụ thể kỹ
hơn sau A
ờ
ờ có cái đến tức à được xem sao thế mà
giỏi
khi tăng số lượng có từ từ đúng không ạ
Cho xem đơn hàng đã đặt ạ
Ừ Ok bây giờ nè
Cho xem đơn hàng đã đặt Ok
không về đâu rồi Sao mình khác admin rồi
mà ừ
Anh An Ninh Hình ở Đăng nhập tuổi
khi đăng nhập Tôi không ngờ đăng nhập
amin rồi à chưa Đã kệ thôi
thì nhân viên
cá nhân viên có phải bấm vào không được
không ạ Chưa có
cho những khách hàng
ở ngân hàng đã từng sử 12 Đơn
thì các bạn lên kiểu nên kiểu liệt kê rõ
ra là giống như vừa nãy bạn kia ra thì
nó phân loại rõ ra là những cái đơn chưa
được duyệt nhận đơn đã duyệt rồi đã hủy
được nó vẫn còn nhiều tình trạng để bấm
vào nó dễ quản lý và có tìm kiếm cả phấn
tra nữa tốt nói chung đón buộc thì các
bạn thế này cũng tương đối rồi Thế cũng
được tiếp theo nhóm ba đúng nhóm bao nhỉ
xem có
Ê mày nhóm đầu vậy khó ổi nhóm 3
nghe
thắc mien crack
bộ phim sex 3D
em đón thích Ninh Bình
hay đổi thành đấy
khi
format caters đấy à
về giá cũ giảm mới xe máy nhà máy dùng
cái hàm cho được về sửa lại bây giờ cũ à
khi sex
Ừ cái đấy các bạn ạ nhắn này thôi mày
nghỉ
ờ đúng à Ba Index II
chị xem phim cái gì mà có đoạn Anh
đang hệ sau
mới mua à
à À quên rồi mà tôi xem nhầm vai đây
xe
ga cũ
format number to school C
nhà hàng này nằm trong hết
a number format number máy xanh tại A
em không được
a
Price is right
tôi thử in Hifi ra mà không có cái này
xem nhé
số tự động nhân 1,8 Đúng là lửa
khi sex
à à
Ừ cái này không phải là số nhảy đây
không lại số à à
à à
Em không biết được 2 dao bạn này dùng mà
P8 cái gì đó sẽ không được
không mình không còn dậy ở PB kết nữa
rồi mình dậy được hơn một năm rồi à
Ờ Ờ
thôi cứ tạo Mở quay vụ này đi cứ đặt đã
ở ngoài làm nhà em mất sự cái thật ơi -
Tết rồi mà
à à
chị đánh giá sản phẩm Đua ca sĩ
chị đánh giá kể cả chưa khuya chưa khi
đăng nhập hay đăng ký à Chứ đẳng chưa cả
mua hàng nữa Từ giờ 00 ăn hay lắm
khi đăng nhập về lô hàng này
ở đây Tôi có thể đăng nhập nha Tạm bố và
đăng kí nhé
à à
ở quán có tóc em luôn để gửi mail nhỉ
Ừ ok
password năm
ừ ừ
Ừ
chị cũng rượu notify rồi cũng kẹo gj có
thử thứ được giao hàng này
em bị lỗi cái hô hấp chậm ngừa không
Tôi tạo bỏ qua cái vụ nằm vừa mát đi sửa
nhanh từ đoạn pho mát rồi bạn đấy à
Anh
tên hạnh
cho number đi
sao ý em gái
ở đại muốn làm kẹo tiền cho nó đẹp hơn
nhưng mà chắc là hàng đấy hả mày hết nó
bị lỗi gì đấy
ở ngân hàng được khởi tạo
Anh quay khách này đặt hơn nhiều
Mỹ hủy nhiều như này là nghe về sau mình
làm tính năng cảnh báo nói khách hàng
nón kia đặt Tam Thư không ạ ạ
à à
anh có thể hủy đơn này đang đợi dược lại
Huy khá tốt ok Còn bên admin thôi mà ạ
ừ ừ
khi sex
Ê mày có Superman thôi mọi các bạn về
sau có thể làm da chết à Làm kiểu mã hóa
lại bắt cóc cũng được
à à
khi sex
ở cổng nhà sản xuất
khi tổng nhà nhà sản phẩm à
Ừ cái mấy cái này không quan trọng này
quan trọng cái này và thống kê đôi khi
là thống kê đơn hôm nay cũng được đơn
đang được nên Đây là thống kê đơn đơn
hôm nay này đơn
tổng số đơn hôm nay Hà đơn đang cho
duyệt không không phải hôm nay ông ạ từ
loại thảo dược này ở đơn
chỉ cần xử lý đã nói chung là người sống
có nhiều cái thống kê làm cái gì đấy
tranh thu hồi bạn này hôm kiểm tra tham
khảo Tại mình bạn nhiều nên
ở trên thêm vài cảnh khác xịn sản phẩm
bán chạy nhất kệ tủ lạnh khá hay
Ừ được cái kiểu ngày cũng tương đối
tương đối ổn rồi ngắm mày sẽ bảo vệ được
không tiền trả thêm nhóm này trông có vẻ
ổn Thế em nghỉ à
Phi Nhung về web cảnh khổ
khi mình không làm bên nhúng do mình là
cha mẹ mình cũng không rõ lắm các bạn là
trả lời hộ mình nếu biết qua cả 2 cái
trở mình phát
anh khác
khi sex
cha mẹ chơi thư viện thì không ghét thế
A5
redmi merries
em xem lại tập bay
khi sex
anh nông dân phải can fix
ở
bài 55 rút này à
a a trang điểm vỡ với ảnh giao diện rồi
vợ giao diện rồi
nó thoại bỏ qua
khi đắp mở khóa thì giao diện đi trả tay
sửa sau thử xem thằng Tính năng lên xem
nhóm này đã làm những gì chia ra cấu
hình các biểu thức có vẻ khá ổn rồi
em à Để tôi xem lần cuối sang nhắn một
cái nhóm này kìa ngày mai còn đang tiếp
tục làm hay không xem nữa nhé Tôi đang
nghe ngóng Mày bỏ sửa lỗi
Vì sao nhóm bạn này vẫn đang làm bọn này
mới làm lại mới làm lại ngoài chưa Lại
nhóm để làm lại Ok ngắm mày chắc à
về sau đi Nếu thấy tôi sẽ đánh dấu lại
nữa đánh dấu lại tất cả nhóm đã
ừ ừ
à à
anh
nói xa xưa ai hay không quan trọng nữa
sự quan tâm đời thôi
Em có vào nhóm sim bảo vệ đợt 2 thôi tao
qua
nhà hôm nay đợt 1 1
máy đánh bài đợt 1 này nhóm 5 cho đợt 2
OK tình tiếp đấy Sao nhòm tiếp theo 6A
à à
cho Biti's trông quen quen
đồng hồ fossil chiến sĩ nhạc giờ giờ nó
không thấy chị lắm
ở ngoài luôn làm tôi bất ngờ
à à
ê ê api Hàn Quốc của Long Nhật
anh ạ
36A
sơ đồ trong sĩ nào ảnh nóng đẹp đấy Chọn
máy ảnh khá hợp lý
về giá trong cũng hấp dẫn đấy
đi bóng qua ủng hộ bạn hãy làm đôi ạ ạ
Ừ cái gây Mỗi tội cái này mày cái biểu
tượng này cho bạn lấy ở đâu nó hơi bị à
Không thường người ta về không Để anh cứ
được thưởng màu mè nữa dùng mấy cái ai
cần có Mày cài CS viện đấy nó ổn hơn hơn
là biểu tượng màu mè của ngài
anh đi lỗi tùm lum này chưa đăng nhập mà
em chưa nhận lỗi tùm lum này
Em thử đang xuất vào lại nha xem nhé
à à
ở xã lần trước đăng nhập rồi nó cũng cần
lưu lại
những sự nha Xin lỗi anh
ở đâu thấy gì đâu đúng không
à à
Ồ thông tin đăng nhập gia đình nha Ok ca
sĩ
các bạn các bạn thì chẳng Làm vedette mà
cái độ mấy cái vụ Xperia ZR này nhé
ở arles
ở đây Cái gì
khi sex
ừ ừ
Em không biết mấy cái này là gì luôn
a cho tôi sẽ hỏi mẹ mấy ông ấy sau tắt
mã hóa xưa à
ừ ừ
à à
anh gửi email không cần tải
à Tôi ở nhà pho có tác ạ Ok em xin lỗi
xin lỗi cái nút đăng kí ở đây led bức
tranh tài ở
số
1A còn mùa Ok bạn ạ
Ừ rồi
ờ ờ
à à
Ê HK con hàng cả các bạn Tùy lúc các bạn
mới hiển thị con hàng nữa ngày vì nó dễ
bị Star mình mũi hết hàng mình không bán
nữa đối thủ cạnh tranh thì lắm không có
thông báo lúc nào gì nữa không tải tra
không được bao giờ
có mỗi cái này hiển thị lên à
Ừ kệ số lượng đăng nhập ở đây âm không
biết được không thanh toán ngay đặt hàng
quốc tế Xin lỗi anh nhưng không bấm được
ok à
em nhảy sang cái này hơi tệ của người
dùng nhá mới đúng là phải bấm này có lại
rồi hả
cho người dùng cần không nên kéo nhảy ra
cả nhà Nhà thuốc được
cả hai thùng kèn anh nhìn chồng có bạn
giống như cá ép nó phải mua ấy khó quay
lại
khi chọn xích nhà đầu tư chọn một lối
pháp hồi cho nó xịn bạn này đã làm được
cái vụ kiểu chọn cái này thì sẽ đề xuất
cái này rồi tự chọn khác là đó bị thay
đổi cái hỗn xếp nhóm mày làm rồi ngay
với khách hàng Ok cho ạ Khách hàng muốn
tôi mời amin cho mà ạ
ừ ừ
I love you
hơi Intex rồi hơn em nghĩ bạn tiếng Việt
ở Nếu mày làm giỏi mà không biết mày
không Này làm cái gì
bí mật khẩu mặc định trong
Ha ha cái gì đây
Ừ mẹ virus luôn mật khẩu Ok
ông này lại cho tôi xin mật khẩu mà
một con mua đã
anh không được rồi mật khẩu như thế này
chắc chắn là không phải làm thôi
có bạn ơi à
bí mật khẩu admin
chứ không phải đặt tên bảng trông kết
quá
ở phố đặt render trường
thế nào để password ABC mật khẩu cái này
không báo hỏa Ok không
ừ ừ
Ê Van Der vừa rồi mật khẩu cần cái gì gì
đó so với cùng nhập nghe nhập được vào
nhưng bị tôi à
anh không thành công
đỡ phải à
Ừ thế lừa rồi
à à
a men bố xem bỏ in
a good connect
cô giáo sư Dạo này đi Tại Sao remix Một
là được à
anh không thành công à là từ bây root
ỷ lại vào thư mục chút nữa không bạn là
sai rồi đúng rồi
Anh mặc diện đồ ngoài nhảy sang bên này
đúng người khác làm lịch tâm khác à
Ê mấy ông có biết mấy ông cái nào tự
nhiên cái này cũng là một phong cách
riêng mà bạn đấy Tôi thấy cũng khá hay
nhưng mà nhưng mà hơi bị lệch tâm một tí
đúng không ạ nhé Hôm sau một cách riêng
mà không có trạm thu không đáng giá với
giao diện xóa đối tượng tưởng là như này
à
anh ấy tiễn flash cũng có một cái hay
vấn đây để sang lạc luôn được
Nghe danh sách
Vì sao không có bấm ở đây để mở duyệt
đơn và mê thì đơn anh anh nghỉ không
cá
nhân viên diện tích là như thế nào là
chưa
không không hiểu cái này lắm
Cho xem đơn thấy nó bạn nên ưu tiên đến
mới lên trước này ra là cái như thế này
là đơn cũ để không quấy Đúng không Đúng
không nhỉ Đấy đúng rồi 13 này 15 này tôi
đến cuối rồi nhảy sang trang thứ hai ông
ạ Không có đơn nào mới cho đặt đơn mới
để mà ấn nghỉ việc rồi
không không quan trọng về đến việc xanh
hay giao diện gì à Tao nói việc trải
nghiệm người dùng khi dung còn cái màu
này bạn ơi chuyển đổi giống màu được mà
không ạ Không đáng giá với màu sắc hai
cái gì cả Nói về cách bố trí ở sao cho
một tiện người dùng thì bạn này trông có
vẻ ổn
Ý tôi là đương nhiên nó Cái quan trọng
Tôi đã nói nói bị lệch tông so với cái
thằng kia thì giao diện bên kia hai
thằng nên thống nhất nhau một tí còn màu
như nào bảo rồi sửa một loại xe S là bao
nhiêu màu gì trắng lung linh đồ ăn hay
các bạn ốp ốp giao diện về thì nó còn
Lung Linh nữa quan trọng là cách ta
dưa tại bến Super cái gì nữa khi ông
không ai làm như thế cơ à
số nhân viên là thằng làm nhiều việc hơn
ông chứ ông lại để cho ông làm nhiều
việc viên
cần như là nhân viên sẽ là người thêm
sản phẩm thẩm và duyệt thậm chí là nếu
mà ông làm cẩn thận hơn thì chị cho chủ
thêm sản phẩm cũng được để cho nhân viên
thì mình tinh nhưng mà nhưng mặt thường
nhiều nơi để chủ chỉ cần vào xem thống
kê cả sẽ những ân nhân viên làm chế độ
như nào duyệt đơn như thế nào thì đơn
như thế nào thôi còn không thì toàn bộ
những cái quá trình mặt thường xuyên làm
việc là là cái đơn hàng đúng không Thì
phải thằng Nhân viên làm nhé chứ chủ làm
việc nhiều hơn nhân viên thì chủ nhân
viên sửa à
Ừ ok ờ
xe 67 năm sau thấy ông nội sang bậy rồi
mà ừ
ở hiện tại nãy giờ có khá nhiều nhóm ổn
không Mày không mấy ông có sợ kiểu chị
quá à
ừ em ừ rồi super nữa
Đúng rồi vừa có xóa cho rồi Nhớ mà như
thế chủ không được gì á hơi sai đúng
không chủ để toàn quyền được Chủ Đây là
toàn quyền
anh giúp đỡ sợ là khi mà ông lão đuổi
hết Nhân viên hỏi rằng ăn hôm nay chưa
Tìm ông Ngọc hay thế thì đơn ông không
ai chưa
ngon ông có tự hạ bậc được bản thân mình
để duyệt đơn không Hai ông tạo thêm tài
khoản mới
à à
thế thôi bao nhiêu lần bảo nhóm này con
gái làm giao diện này lần cuối Họ trình
do ông con trai lạ như vậy chồng chị ấy
luôn được hả Nó đây em ở đây nhìn Tam
Muội á trải nghiệm người dùng thế không
tốt đâu
Mọi chuyện đang hot
ừ ừ
Ừ ok karaoke Không biết có đúng hay
không nữa Kế
anh bấm là âm được
khi sex
khi
đăng nhập không được cha bên này chưa có
ngại danh thôi
An
đăng ký đăng nhập vào đây Đang dấy trợ
chỗ ở
tạm con trai chưa nhập Ok
chuyện với các máy bơm nước ra đường
link của nhóm mày lỗi hơn nhiều À à
Vì
sao web đọc truyện thôi không không có
yêu
cầu điện thoại
không phải biết cái ly cái gì đây đây
đây diện chữ ạ phải là cũng được không
được chức rau mở được bên nhóm 2 nhà
mình Linh hỏi nhỉ Đây nhau hay rất cần
được tiện ích mà tôi thường bảo nói tiện
ích để mà nó weblio ơi
là không không mà nhóm gì à Cũng không
phải cái này nó cái gì nhỉ
ra quân xử lợi ích của tôi từng bảo là
để lại trách xe mà đường minh của vấn đề
nóng này rất cần cái đấy luôn
đâu nhỉ
bấm vào sẽ đánh giá luôn cả trang web A
cái trang web các bạn cốt đường link của
vấn đề như thế nào để mình sửa
Ừ để tìm lại nha Lại thượng Thích
web và blog tơ đánh giá check à
expansion
Sợ nhảy sang để chất đích vừa rồi
chứ không phải không phải
I never không phải tế bào nhỏ có cái
tiện ích để mà hồi trước nó là trách cả
đường link
a Slap 43
khi sex
chứ không phải youwestlife
à à
anh ạ
Các bạn thấy rất nhanh nhé
say
Xuân mặt chiều về
Nghe nhạc vàng
I
fall is low này
ăn rau kiểm tra tốc độ trang web cũng an
ninh cần
à à
ở
thời sự cứ thử mở lại cái web Perfect
này hình như nó để xem thử ở lại nhé
ô tô màu nhỏ nhất à
2003 không ạ ạ
ở
đây chắc Mai Linh đây đây
này à
Chị
xem ngày hôm nay bị hỏng lỗi bao nhiêu
đường đấy nhé
à à
những đại gia này
Em bấm vào phải chị Mary nó à
Em đâu rồi
Có ai biết link không có invalid
ở Hà Tây mới không gắn thẻ ra luôn thì
bảo ra không có vẻ là lỗi ạ sẽ bấm lại
vào bên trang chủ nhé
Chứ không lẽ nó không có cái nào không
bị invalid à
Chắc cái này nó không chết cả MT rồi có
linh linh trống này chứ thần linh này
linh chồng ơi ở đâu bên anh trọn đến
Index luôn ạ
anh ạ
ở đây là chọn Iraq vẫn đúng đúng
Ừ ok
Ừ để ích này không thể giúp được gì Bởi
vì bạn đấy chính bạn đấy đã Để Linh rồi
nha vẫn giờ để Linh trai thôi
Anh không trách được rồi là
từ nhỏ Isabella mini
các bạn này là bạn khá cầu kỳ mà xã hội
thì các bạn nên nên nên là nên để chống
Linh nó ạ nên để chồng lên để mà dùng
cái tiện ích để kiểm tra chứ không phải
gắn link rồi y như thế ấy không thể kiểm
tra được kiểm tra toàn cơ mất đúng không
ạ
Xin chào bạn không biết cái đấy vợ tôi
mới Chỉ mà
à à
anh hơn tôi kéo ấn an ninh chất phạt
chút ở đến 8 nhanh thêm chuyện xóa
chuyện thêm chương này chúng chị mà
không mấy cái này thì như là tôi nhớ
không giờ không bấm được bạn này quen
thì Xóa đi Ấy đoạn này không bấm được vì
vậy chị có dừng lại anh thôi I
Ừ cái này bấm được tiến hành
tìm tiền chuyện thêm chuyện thêm Trương
thêm trường chọn truyện của chọn chuyện
kiểu này chết lại không tốt cái này nên
là bấm vào chuyện cho nó thì thêm trường
nói chuyện đấy ổn hơn ai tìm kiếm thế
có gì đấy
du
lịch Việt
wi-fi chưa cập nhật cốc rồi
thiếu mất tên của tôi i
khi xem clip cả thế giới
không
bấm được kiểm tra mình nghĩa ổn rồi ok
năm chị nhé
truyện hay truyện Thái
À đấy mấy ông nếu béo để kỹ đã được ra
là cách để mà thay đổi cái biểu tượng
vào đây Nếu thấy mắc định đối tượng đây
nhóm đánh em phải có những cái ai cần ở
đây để thay đổi hình tượng đấy tôi chưa
nói ngon tôi tiền thì tớ nói qua về tục
nhớ ra đấy thì nó sẽ viết là nằm trong
thể hét thôi Nó là bạn tra là kiểu ai
cần Ngạn HTML cũng ra
à mà không ạ Nó là gì nhỉ Xì tên rồi thế
cách hồi hồi đấy thôi không biết làm nhà
tôi không biết em mà nói những cách
nhanh để bạn biết một cái gì đó Đơn giản
thôi các bạn lên hẳn chính Ví dụ mày cái
xa như thế này không ạ Các bạn can tru
các bạn xem được thực ra là cái cái cái
cái cái ảnh này nó lấy từ đâu
cho ngoại mày trang này mày dạng này nó
viết 2 Bảng giá quý rồi
chúng nó ừ đấy thì thực ra lúc đầu các
bạn không biết nó pha với cân nữa là ví
dụ tôi vừa rộn quên rồi Là nó không thì
mới ông lên một cái trang bước đi không
còn cái sao đâu ở trang WAP hay cho
Google cũng được Google cho Cốt nó nhắn
ngay cả nhận đúng không Bạn thấy bức
tượng này không các bạn gần cho nu u
những hot girl Hà thành vẫn viết ra sức
bật
của sẽ xem được cái nó sẽ có cái ảnh của
nó đúng không thì các bạn sẽ xem được có
cái đoạn và tôi cần nóng không
Ê hồi nãy giờ tôi có là tôi có tôi biết
được là từ bên Facebook cơ nha Facebook
phiên bản mới giờ nó toàn bằng ra Swift
lên thời ra hơi khó đâu mà xem
phải cần vậy nha
ô
tô cha của đấy Chả bằng ai cần nhấn lại
được Mày không biết gì đâu tra thôi nó
sẽ ra cái kiểu như này à
anh như hình như thế này giống nhau đúng
rồi đúng rồi đấy có bạn sẽ thấy có cái
đoạn này cho các bạn copy về còn sửa với
đường đây nè đường link đó bạn không ạ ạ
vì nó không
tôi tôi nhớ rồi đấy tôi căn the new cái
trang Google nó là HTML thật nó HTML
Thật ra bây giờ là biến anh ấy phải ra
Speed thằng nào cũng thích làm một ra
Speed đấy nó pin dịch ra thành HTML hơi
khó chịu thì đấy vì tôi tôi thử Ví dụ
nhé ví dụ là Trang Trang nhóm chí này
đúng không Thì ví dụ cho vào trang này
đấy các bạn xem này nên là để trong cái
thư mục hét thì nó tốt
kiểu ngay tránh em bảo ta lại này đó các
bạn hãy cũng tượng ký khác ở đây rồi
thấy không cái thì nó sẽ được tới thì
nếu các bạn không biết từ khóa vừa rồi
bạn kia biết từ khóa đúng không ạ Các
bạn học trước các bạn được biết với vân
vân Nhưng nếu các bạn không muốn biết
thì chỉ đơn giản như cho tôi vừa bảo nó
tôi thấy có cái trang này có đúng không
ạ thì thôi container Xem cốt của nó thì
cho icon đúng họ cái đấy biểu tượng mà
Thì ai cần số đó thì ra được cô về chạy
được là ổn không ạ a cho mình thay bằng
cái của mình mình nó chẳng quan tâm so
với cần là cái gì cản đấy đúng không đấy
Ở đấy tôi thường tôi thường anh rất để
những trang web khác như thế nào cũng
bắt chước mình sẽ concho Samsung cốt của
nó hoa inspect để xem nó đã làm như thế
nào với luôn Vân Liệu mình có về nhưng
bây giờ nó làm hết mà ra Khuyết Như vừa
rồi Mày không thấy thì ra hơi khó này mà
bắt chước thì các bạn ở nice pic thì vẫn
xem mình HM nhé inspect cái nó vẫn à
phát em được biên dịch hết rồi thì các
bạn xem được cái gì
à à I shall cuối năm anh chị nào ạ là
một tội lại hình như sau Diện hơi bị vỡ
hai ngày tôi đang run
em học sinh sinh viên được giảm 5-phần 5
anh ra giật Tít chứ thực ra làm gì có
chuyện đấy tôi đăng ký cái thứ làm gì
chuyện chứ
thì anh vào không Ok
hay do đường dẫn của bạn ấy bị ghi đè
lên cái thư mục chí này nên nó biến
thành báo cáo Thế theo
chi nhánh sửa lại
Nó xin lại không phải đã ok ok hay mà
được
khi trộn nữ chân nhỏ ở
có điều Trần cũng là một cách tốt
ghi đè lên cái Thanh địa chỉ hơi nhiều
người khó chịu đấy à
Vì sao cứ phải này bị mất phải sẽ thì
phải suy nghĩ như thế đúng không Chắc là
thế mất phải sẽ rồi à Chắc là do cái
đường giận nó ra bạn ấy đang dùng đường
dẫn tuyệt đối cái này nó bị mất nó hết
cả phải xé rồi mình như thế này tôi
không sao Bỏ qua quan tâm mình giao diện
đâu
em có chịu nghỉ đậu xanh à
10 sản phẩm như nào này vào trang chủ
vậy nhỉ
khi đàn ông ở sản phẩm đi
ở
đó mà không được đi
anh Linh không có gì vậy
ở thời sự sản cốt lái xe máy à
em inbox ngày đầu ngon ơ
à à Vãi chưởng mẹ đang làm để mua
ở đây là có phải đẻ đây là để mua chứ
lấy xe Vợ tôi thích pro II
ở các đời tươi Xem nhóm mày đang tiến độ
nha à
a99
khi
thiếu phần đăng nhập bên admin và phần
đặt hàng bị khách hàng
nhiều cái này từ lâu rồi
Từ trước Tết rồi
ngắm này của Củi khô đấy Củi khô đâu rồi
quy khô hôm nay hình như cũng chưa on gì
vậy ạ
à à
chi tiết sản phẩm có chạy à
à mà chơi đặt hàng hả
ừ ừ
Ừ
ông kia là ông ban nữa
khi exo OOO
ở cuối Cô đang ăn Tết Rồi
à À không phải rước đèn hai nữa chị mà
mẹ dùng đường dẫn tuyệt đối này ra ngoài
kiểu nó cứ xóa những cái xóa đi cái
đường dẫn này đi
Ừ
Ok nói chuyện cho tôi xem thằng cốt rồi
nhé em nói chồng về tương đối đầy đủ rồi
Ai biểu đồ thống kê luôn đấy không xin
nghỉ
tạm cho bảo vệ đợt 1 xem trong nha
khó quá
à Xuống sợ
Đúng rồi đấy tình trạng kinh doanh để
tôi rất muốn xem nào hay bảo vệ đất một
như thế nào
được
một cái shop
em Google chấm chín Ngoại ok nhóm 11
thông tin nhanh nhanh hả Bây giờ 9 giờ
rồi Xin lỗi mày không hơn tiếng này ở
thế mà cũng cho 10 chấm được à à
sơ mi chấm được chữa đấy mưa nhóm ạ Cho
hôm nay không kịp với mấy ông cứ có bình
luận tâm sự tâm sự luôn đi nha rồi mà
tầm mà Bởi Chắc là sông màu căng nhất
thì mình sẽ được đi học nữa thôi không
nên dài quá lắm ạ
ừ ừ
khi ngồi công nhận là giới trẻ bây giờ
kể tiếp xúc công nghệ sớm học nhanh mà
Nhưng mà
thực ra cũng không sao cái cái mình cứ
nói rồi Nhiều người nghĩ rằng là tiểu
học lập trình này cần phải thông minh
cần phải cậu nhanh nhẹn để mà học họ
nhanh lên Vân thì mình thấy là không
không đúng lắm nó mình tự nói đây rồi đó
thực ra là mình theo cái ngành này là
mình cần phải kiên nhẫn như nó bởi vì
nhiều ông kiểu học được thông minh học
nhanh nhưng mà mất kiên nhẫn thì khi mà
bị khách hàng thay đổi yêu cầu hay là
được thay đổi công nghệ bạn ấy sẽ bị làm
bạn sẽ bỏ vẩn ạ Bạn ấy sẽ kiểu quen làm
việc là
nhanh rồi
không không thức diện tích cực không
kiểu quen được thích đi không quen việc
ở thay đổi liên tục thì bạn sẽ khó chịu
ở ngoài hồi chơi có chữ shopee đây mà
ông ấy đổi thành nhóm 11 đấy à
tổ chức năng có
khó chịu uống sữa lại cái chữ info ấy
nhá đổi hết lại tiếng Việt đi
ở shopee phiên mặt đạo nhạc à
thứ ba ngày chả
để ý
ý theo dõi hàng sexy Ok Ok Ok bạn
xin lỗi
header cái này ở Liên quan việc
hết đồ bị bị điều hướng hai phát này hết
đồ làm gì đó
Hà Nội rồi
cho sự phát ở
I had Mina
khách hàng đúng
a
kerio
rồi ở dưới này lại có thêm một cái ships
Tab nữa thành cáo lỗi mà không Đây đây
đây Tôi từng nói đó là đó các bạn nếu mà
các bạn có hết rồi Như này các bạn phải
để lên đầu vì các bạn mỗi khi mà lại cho
bất kỳ cái HTML nó ra rồi các bạn không
hết đợt nữa nên các bạn sẽ phải chèn
thêm cái đoạn này ở ngay đầu này mình nó
mới đúng này này
Ê thằng chuột
nó
ít thiếu chính vậy
em
nói thế này Vui lòng đăng Nhật đái
ở ngã tư sửa luôn cốt của ông đấy Tí tôi
dậy lên Nhậu
Đăng nhập đăng ký đăng nhập với tin nhắn
à
à À tôi biết cho bạn Này gấu Này nhá Cứ
mỗi lần mà Bình Linh mà có dấu chấm than
đằng sau ai là rất giàu thăng bằng ra
uống sẽ được cho chức năng nhận không có
đây
Ok em nhậu đi
xe lửa
à
Dạ nhà hạnh phúc pin ở mức tương đối
tài chính chỉ có thế thôi thời gian thì
có thấy tôi sẽ làm ngồi rồi à
để
sex luôn thêm tiền cái này nó cái hay mà
giống như là tôi từng nói là mày ông làm
đồ ăn một này là các bạn chỉ bảo là mức
tương đối các bạn khó mà làm một cái
hoàn thiện các bạn chỉ cần là mức tương
đối trong cái khoảng thời gian trong 3
tháng các bạn làm được một cái khung làm
được tương đối đầy đủ tính năng cơ bản
sau đó thì các bạn đi bảo vệ và những
cái tính năng làm à các bạn có thể bổ
sung Vì vẫn sẽ hỏi được rồi trong buổi
bảo vệ và thệ và chính bạn làm bạn làm
kiểu này cũng là một cái từng nói được
theo cả là là kẹo là một cái khung giãn
và để và nghĩ trước thì nó để mà sao để
mà gần như cũng là chào hàng ấy ra sửa
cái này giờ các bạn làm để mô cho một
ông đó ông ấy ông ấy lúc đầu mà chỉ muốn
làm trong web được bán nếu bây giờ toàn
nghĩa em làm cho web nhanh nhanh nhanh
cho anh chồng 11 tuần hai tuần gì đấy
chỉ cần đăng một vài sản phẩm được mà
đấy kèo kiểu nhá ông làm tương đối này
sao rồi những tính năng
có vẻ trông hay như thế nhờ có thể bảo
là ông trả thêm tiền cho tôi cho tôi
thêm thời gian thì tôi sẽ làm nốt tính
năng này cho ông thì chắc chắn là sẽ khá
ra ổn người kia sẽ sẵn sẽ hoàn toàn thấy
muốn trả thêm tiền thôi ông ạ Nhưng mà
nếu người kia cũng chả liên tiền thì
không phải làm cái gì đó Lên mà còn cả
tính năng này nhanh người dùng trên
người dùng bấm vào cái gì nó cũng chức
năng chế hiện có không ai mua trong
không ai mua trang web của ông đâu
Chào ông lại dùng giết thôi kiểm tra tất
cả các thẻ nào mà mà chưa gửi xe ngừng
như vừa rồi ông làm đúng không ạ Ông xóa
đi hộ ăn ông ẩn ở đi đúng không mà dùng
ra sweep ẩn hạn game thể nằm ở chữ ấy
cũng được toàn bộ đoạn này bay hết à
Chị đặt xe mà
Ừ cái gì Chức năng có lẽ không đùa tôi à
à
à à em
coi đổi nhật à
à à
âm thanh toán thao tác cà phê
khi họ mua đồ cái thử tiếp theo rồi đặt
hàng thành công Ok đâu Xem mã đơn mà đơn
mua kể
có gì lỗi anh à hả Không xin lỗi dầu
diễn trôi xuống đã vì đang chờ duyệt
cũng được được bên bên của khách hàng để
ý thì không cần phải tìm kiếm Hà Phương
Trang kìa nhau hơi xa nhiều cũng cần cân
nhắc mà tải ứng dụng quay chúng sinh mà
copy khi lại thuộc về
chẳng có chữ nha trở thành người bán
luôn Ồ chị này Xin hãy để tôi xem được
Để tao bề ngoài làm kiểu gì mà bị biến
thành người bán được
customer mà Em làm thế nào biến thành
rán hay đây lại biến thành tính năng à
Đấy biết ngay có thêm với thằng Hậu Mày
lừa
xe lửa Huy nhiễu
gì thế Tao Tao đây này không không thiết
kế để mà cho thành người bán được
Ừ đúng rồi lên đưa cả đơn mới mới đã đặt
lên đầu nữa đơn bánh xèo dượt như tiền
nữa đâu ạ
Em bấm vào đây này bấm vào đây để xem
này ra ổn này cũng được được
khi nãy như này ổn này chờ lấy hàng
hỗ trợ xanh Ok good Ừ nếu ăn nhiều lửa
admin xem à à
ừ ừ
Ừ ông kia bây giờ mới vào hay sao mà đã
bây giờ mới chạy Hello anh này
không được đấy à
1234123 Tôi sẽ lại mê gọi đi
à à Không lấy được mail của Superman để
xem sơ mi làm những gì
bí mật khẩu mật khẩu mã hóa
anh quản lí nhân viên à à à
cách quản lý này chắc không thêm được
cái Superman quản lý hóa đơn chi tiết
không không không nên có quản lý hóa đơn
chi tiết cụ thể hóa đơn thôi Bấm rồi xem
chi tiết không nên quản lý hoạt linh chi
tiết sẽ em trong tiến Tìm kiếm nó không
biết tìm kiếm cái gì nữa thời gian đặt
để đầu được rồi lại thông tin nữa có vẻ
ổn Đấy tìm kiếm tìm kiếm cái gì nhỉ
Mình kiếm số điện thoại được
chứ không có câu không bấm được tính
điểm này cho vui bên này thì không hiển
thị chức năng ngày xưa có ạ
à à nhà sản xuất
Ừ thôi Nói chung là bên này thì cơ bản
thôi ạ Chưa gì đặc sắc cho tập trung hết
địch năng chưa có ở bên bên đó khách
hàng lỗi Ok nhóm 13
thì chả khó mà có thể à
thì khó mà có thể kiểu chấm hết rồi cho
bộ mày rồi mày không cứ tâm sự nhé Tâm
sự trong vòng 15 phút nó lại Tôi với ông
nói bất kỳ cái gì cũng được để mà à
ở nhà mà tôi sẽ thử Tâm Sự Mộng
à à
khi sex
có giao diện giống bên là bản quyền Thực
ra là cái về bản quyền ấy không ấy Thực
ra là khó vì
có nhiều Trang đi hẳn copyright Nhưng
thực ra là dẫn gần đây ông thể làm giả
mạo này mình bà không mục đích thương
mại thứ khó mà lãng mạn quyền ta khó
tiện cả lắm
Ừ
Thôi mình cứ tạm chấm những nhóm sau sau
nha Xin lỗi Mình đã quen chấm nhóm từ
đầu đến cuối mà anh không đủ thời gian
thì chắc là hai để buổi sau đi bởi sau
mình chấm Tiếp đi để các bạn bắt đầu từ
nhóm 13 vậy nhá số này cũng sốc bao giờ
nhóm 13 Các bạn cứ tiếp tục làm để mà
thứ năm mình sẽ lại chậm tiếp nhé Để ông
ạ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ chuẩn có tâm sự
một tí đi
web đồ ăn mua thì mình không Yêu cầu
phải deposit không ạ
các bạn mới học các bạn mới học này nên
xem video từ đầu thôi Chứ xem buổi hôm
nay thì chắc là nhìn mấy anh này thì
trông cũng rất là ngầu mình và thực là
cũng vì ngầu nhé Anh ấy là các bạn học
từ đầu cũng thể
nhá nhái được làm tương tự được cái
giống ai đón Hay mình không dậy thêm về
giao diện và mình sẽ dạy các bạn ăn cắp
thợ Xịn về để mà làm hơn ở
vì
mình không biết về sping Hà do bao lắm
mình dậy các bạn về pp thôi
cho mấy bạn này sinh năm mà không không
Bạn này ở khẳng tất cả bạn này từ nhóm
như tin computer
mình không biết được tuổi các bạn Nhưng
mà thường là các bạn vẫn đang học đại
học hoặc là thậm chí có bạn cấp 3 có có
bạn cũng có nhà nước mình là bạn đấy 30
tuổi rồi cũng người mới bắt đầu học của
mình nên là nói chung là mọi đối tượng
mà nó nhọn ra ai có nhu cầu học thì học
mà Ok hai cái năm kia tôi cảm thấy tôi
già đãy tôi không hôm trước tôi mình
nhận ra về tuổi 25 tuổi thôi ra Vãi tôi
vẫn nghĩ tôi hai mươi mấy ông ạ thấm
thía 18 thì nó hơi quá Nhưng mà Bởi vì
mình ra trường lâu rồi thì không thể
nhận mình phải dạng nữa nhiều Tôi vẫn
nghĩ tới 20 tôi Đôi khi tôi gặp những
người khác rồi vẫn gọi mình là em thôi
rõ ràng mà người ta ở trong người ta đô
thị ở trong trưởng thành hơn tôi thật
mặt với món tuổi mòn chuột nhưng mà à
anh mới nhận ra mình 25 sợ bạn
nào thầy dạy cho ăn cắp thì nó hơi quá
dùng để ăn cắp bởi vì nó hơi bị thôn một
tí như thế thì ông không hệ xin người ta
mà ông đã đi lấy giao diện người ta
nhưng mà nhưng mà đấy gọi là đi cóp nhặt
tôi bảo rồi nó không có đánh bản quyền
những thể tôi sẽ chỉ mấy ông rất nhiều
Mình tra miễn phí hay mấy ra không đánh
quyền về mấy ông hoàn toàn thì lấy giao
diện về mà nó không ạ Hòa tôi sẽ cho vợ
mấy ông mấy cái template này mấy ông có
thể ốp vào sau A
ừ ừ
Anh
có vợ con chưa Lòng Tôi chưa có vợ con
đấy à đấy có một con chó thôi I
bài hát đó Hay tôi khuyên mày ông có đi
ăn trộm giao diện rồi nhé phải ăn trộm
cả trang web về
à à à à
Ừ đúng rồi thì bên đấy đồ ăn hay chắc
chắn là mình phải chia sẻ các bạn về
cách lấy
ốp màu giao diện nào đó về nhanh chưa
vừa ngồi sửa CS rồi ta thường Thứ hành
chính mình cũng khá là lại mấy vụ đấy
Nó gọi nó ghim ôxit rồi các thử ngon mà
à à
anh
không Mình thì chưa làm mát bao giờ em
mình khó dậy nhớ Bây giờ có một cái hay
gọi là web này đó là em bây giờ có thể
nhấc được quét các bạn Và thậm chí là
web các bạn bây giờ có thể bấm cái nút
để mà nó biến hình áp các bạn biết rồi
đấy ông ạ để mà sách nó lại nhá phải
trên điện thoại thế bạn lên trong béo
rồi các bạn biến thêm nút tắt
vào màn hình chính nó sẽ biến thành
những kiểu dạng web lấy hạt web ép với
cái kia thì và các bạn thấy tiện như thế
như thế này các bạn chỉ reponship vào
được rồi
mình thì mình cốt mình mình cái thấy cô
chai này nhưng mình sẽ kết codeless là
dành cho cháu là nhớ hơn và cô thì
crackinh hơn
anh hả
em bỏ 3 phần đầu mà hãy chuyển sang phần
học ăn trộm không ăn trộm về đâu vẫn
phải sử dụng biết cái sửa chứ Thế nè Tôi
vẫn phải dạy Công về HTML sẽ cơ bản để
mấy ông về sau biết cái sửa đúng không ạ
Thế các bạn ăn trộm về mà ôm lấy nguyên
như thế không ổn không ạ Các bạn sẽ phải
sửa lại Tết vừa rồi anh có tăng cân
không không Tết vừa rồi là của vì cái
rồi Tôi ở một mình có rất nhiều vấn đề
Tôi đang ở một mình anh hiểu cần nó chỉ
giảm rồi tôi một thằng hơi bị kiểu quen
ngồi cả ngày trên máy tính nên không
biết cách chăm sóc bản thân lắm Em đừng
như rồi
ờ ờ
cũng hay đi ăn cắp giao diện về mà nó
lỗi tùm lum lạ lắm Nếu thế thì chả bạn
phải tham khảo xem vì sao mình dạy cách
ăn cắp giao diện về sự xem thế nào
mình đang làm ở trong công ty thôi nhưng
mà anh ta rất là tự do đúng nghĩa là khá
tự do luôn là sự nhà mình hướng lên thế
nào cốt Bởi vì thứ ba cái ngành này nó
nên thế này này thì nó khó mà kiểu ốp
này nào các bạn phải làm đúng giờ hay là
kiểu phải làm đúng tiến độ gì gì đó có
những hôm mà mình có thể đó mình vẫn
mình thoải mái mình sẽ làm rất là nặng
năng động nhưng có năng suất nhưng mà có
những hôm thì mình thì ra là mình đau
đầu do mình buồn chán gì đó Bây giờ là
không nên để tâm lý ảnh hưởng lắm nghe
bởi vì mình hướng ngoại nên ảnh hưởng
cái cảm xúc nhiều nhưng mà vì những ngày
hôm như thế thì da mình cốt càng cốt đấy
càng cố ấy thì Cốt nó sẽ rất là rò và
cũng đi mình không nghĩ ra đó không minh
mẫn không nghĩ được
tư vấn đề thế nên là các bạn càng Cốt nó
sẽ chỉ cần thêm đổi thôi vào hôm sau
phải sửa cái Đông lỗi nữa thành ra hôm
đấy Mình nghĩ nên để tâm trạng thoải mái
nghỉ ngơi cái con hôm nào mà kiểu nhưng
mà đỡ như ông phải bù lại bằng những cái
hôm mà các bạn tỉnh táo các bạn Minh vẫn
có những hôm mà một ngày tôi làm Tận năm
sáu cái công việc làm làm xong hết làm
rất nhanh đấy và có những hôm mà tôi khó
tôi mở máy chưa thêm cái này nó triệu
rưỡi không phải lên công ty game nhưng
mà nhưng mà tôi không làm được là thử
cái sếp cũng hiểu lầm thiếu ở bỏ xin
phép nghỉ nghỉ buổi hôm đấy cũng được
không sao cơ mọi việc sếp chắc à sẽ hơi
bị nhân nhượng với tôi và sếp cũng kiểu
cũng biết được Tôi là con người hiểu là
mà làm chưa trôi và cũng cậu nhiệt huyết
ý cho tôi không làm kiểu đối phó với tôi
không hề làm thì còn đối phó nên sẽ được
Kiểu cũng rất là thoải mái rồi Hơi bị
chuẩn bị nấu mì trí sau nhân viên khác
về tôi cũng là một thằng cậu cũng làm
được việc được thế Tôi muốn mấy ông được
như thế đó kiểu mấy ông thoải mái nên
thoải mái như thế thì hoàn toàn với ông
làm được rất tốt Nếu nghe thấy về thú vị
không ạ với ông hộ hôm nào muốn làm thì
làm và làm giữa các tâm huyết ngay lên
nó đang mất ngủ được nhưng có những hôm
mà công kiểu cảm thấy chán có độ suy
nghĩ sẽ vẫn thoải mái thế được nó Ngoại
ạ
ở công ty của mình hiện tại thì hồi
trước ở không nhận thực tập Nhưng bây
giờ có nhận thực tập rồi mà chỗ ở có thể
do mình ở Anh Tuấn Đào tạo đấy nhưng mà
cái đấy Kiểu gì cũng nhưng mà vẫn phải
qua phỏng vấn để mà xem cái không phải
nóng lực mà xem cái cái nhiệt huyết của
bạn về công ty có Vân Nham nữa Xem cái
gọi là cái tư duy tư duy kiểu suy nghĩ
một cách logic có phù hợp với không
bực Tại sao phải gọi là phù hợp với việc
sinh viên mình ngồi thước từng có một
vài bạn sinh viên tôi rất là ổn nhưng
bạn ấy sự tư duy nó kiểu bị Hơi bị lệch
với mọi người một tí anh ra làm nên
những sản phẩm mà tôi từng nói có những
lập trình viên rất giỏi nhưng làm những
sản phẩm mà không ai dùng được hay không
ai muốn dùng ạ tại bãi tư duy ở rất là
rắc rối hỏi ăn làm cho một cái sản phẩm
rất khó sử dụng thì cái đấy không phù
hợp với với ít nhất là với công ty thôi
công ty tôi ở đang hướng đến là nhiều
người sử dụng này ạ để thế
em có kênh disko đấy Ok dysport cho
trong cho cho cha có phải bạn hôm nay
chắc được đề xuất thêm cho nhiều bạn mới
nhiều bạn mới về đã hỏi tôi để lại đi
con này
em
21 tuổi mà bị thoát vị đĩa đệm 150 cốt
học được
ờ ờ
cho
tôi chưa bị dính với mấy cái vụ mà nhiều
ông lại bị trĩ thì tao thú vị đĩa đệm
với tội không thì dụng lực lên như thế
nào lắm nhưng mà Đúng là mấy ông lên
mình kiểu Cải thiện sức khỏe với ngành
này nó bị vắt Kiệt cả sức lao động theo
kiểu là chất xám nó cả là sức khỏe của
mình nhưng mình ông lại cải thiện 10 vụ
đấy
công ty Có gái không
cô gái rất là công ty làm có bởi vì bởi
vì kế toán này nhân sự này mất tinh này
chúng mày chắc chắn nó có còn better hay
lập trình viên ý thì mình có đến tán
đồng nghiệp còn em đi nhất là không nên
tán những cái đứa mà kẹp có thể ngồi
chửi mình thì cố tình giọt không Bơ nên
dán thế luôn
chị đây
anh có dung dịch cao su không
nửa có nữa không Tôi từng mua vịt cao su
nhưng mà có vẻ không dùng nhiều nhưng mà
tôi vẫn thường hay biến người khác hình
con vịt cao su của mình mà giảm cố trợ
họ lấy sẽ cho ra tự mình nói chuyện
chính mình thôi I
ờ ờ muốn Tổng hợp một bộ vài bộ hướng
dẫn sử dụng Cốt
vì vậy cách Floral
khi bạn dùng vạn tự code trai để có thôi
Em không hiểu ý bạn lắm nhưng ko thì
đương nhiên các bạn nên kết hợp cả tôi
rách kìa mà kéo lọc dữ liệu nữa
Cho xin tên công ty ở công ty của mình
tên là chevron đấy thời gian các bạn
thực mấy lần để ý rồi mà nhận có đĩa
mình cũng mình không mình không công
khai nhưng mình cũng định ở đây ạ mình
không công khai bí thư cả có như không
có thể kiểu đến Đâm bụng Tôi gửi Tôi
từng chặng khá nhiều về trong tim
committee không biết nhưng mà tôi có thể
nói được đây vì cho rằng mấy ông ấy
không vừa xem livestream của tôi đến giờ
này đâu
Ừ đúng rồi mấy ông muốn có tester nửa
đêm ngắn mà có cái mất này này anh anh
dậy Facebook đi thế chết đấy
bạn thân mấy bạn gái đã thường này bắt
lỗi xo nồi ông rồi vừa kết hợp việc bắt
lỗi cả công việc của ông nữa Nếu ông
muốn nghỉ việc thật đấy
Đúng rồi discord ở g-school người khác
với cái code này để mà dành cho các bạn
làm đồ án và mình Thiên các bạn làm đồ
án còn dysport của Jesus cool thì nó
hoãn tất cả mà nó sẽ
rộng hơn
anh Lương mình 1k lương của mình hiện
tại chưa đến 10k bởi vì một phần là thứ
nhất là thực ra tôi không quan trọng về
lương Khi tôi Bởi tôi mới ngủ dậy làm
giảng viên giảng viên ngồi trước từ
hướng dẫn ở cao nhưng mà tôi nhỉ dậy và
tôi khi tôi mới ra này biết biết hồi đầu
thôi anh đi phỏng vấn người ta bỏ tôi
mong Mức lương bao nhiêu thì thôi nói
nào Theo vụt có kinh nghiệm mà tôi kinh
nghiệm thực tế không nhiều nhưng mà tôi
từng gọi làm cái hẳn cái phần mềm cho
nhà trường đấy Mà tôi cũng có thường
xuyên đấy tôi tìm hiểu là leo các thứ
thứ viết ra các thứ hồi đầu đi phỏng vấn
thì mức lương tôi Tôi chỉ hi vọng và 10
triệu nhiều người bất ngờ đấy anh Anh
Tuấn mời tôi về bất ngờ đấy phỏng vấn
Tốt bất ngờ rồi để anh đây còn nghĩ rằng
tôi phải kẹo nổ hai mấy đấy thì nhưng mà
tôi lúc nào tới Chị hi vọng thế vì tôi
thực sự về năm kinh nghiệm rồi chưa đủ
nhiều Tôi nghĩ à Mới lượng Lúc đầu tôi
có thể thế nhưng cho tôi sẽ cố phấn đấu
không phải cố phấn đấu phải tăng lương
mà cố phấn đấu để thể hiện mình là một
người tăng cái lên trình rất là nhanh
kiểu đang từng chúng yêu có thể đến sẽ
khô rất là nhanh chẳng hạn đấy tôi muốn
là như thế nhưng mà đương nhiên là lúc
đầu thì bữa kia đang thuê nhà rồi các
chi phí phát Trinh phát sinh nữa Nếu anh
này vẫn cho tôi mức lương đầu là 15 Bởi
vì ai ở đây Mới làm vừa vào cũng ở 15
sao rồi còn gì sáp nhưng vừa vào trả
lương Thế ra vụn rồi à
Sau đó thì bây giờ đưa sau 2 lần nữa
được review xem xét tăng lương thì tôi
lên lên mỗi lần lên được 2 triệu thôi
à Vì nó không thấy sát không nó vẫn đang
lỗ Hiện tại vẫn lỗ nhưng mà lên thể thao
quần rồi và về sau bọn tôi quan trọng
mọi tôi sẽ được cổ phần nữa của phần nó
sẽ giờ chị rất nhiều
tôi Thực ra tôi nghe mấy cái thôi cả tôi
không quan tâm đây Mang lắm tượng điển
hình Tết này đây này được thưởng Tết rồi
được tiền lương các hư Mình cũng chẳng
biết gì Ngoài việc và đang nghĩ việc mua
thêm 1 cái máy rửa bát được
nơi ấy
cô bạn gái cùng cơ quan thì có động lực
hơn ông đang nói về những ngày tháng màu
hồng tươi đẹp rồi
à Còn những ngày còn những ngày tồi tệ
thì bạn nẽ nè cơ quan
anh
Lương giảng viên Mức lương bao nhiêu
rằng viên ở đại học cho sản lượng nước
hấp rất bèo bọt nhưng rằng viên ở trường
công tư chứng tư của tôi hồi trước nó
trường nghề trường đấy học phí là đắt
cái tờ việc bà tôi dậy cả cả ngày từ thứ
hai đến thứ bảy là nói từ 81 Dài 9 rưỡi
tối
và
tôi bởi vì tối tôi không phải dậy rồi
kéo cho lớp ta lớp bình thường mà tôi sẽ
dạy cho lớp cái bộ tốc những cái lớp mà
lớp dành trọn những người làm học trái
ngành hoặc các huyện Nói chung là sinh
viên trường cát đấy muốn tiểu học thêm
nghề này toàn đôi khi là có mấy anh chị
mấy gọi các bác bụng có 30 40 tuổi đến
nào cơ Không phải để lấy cái bằng nhá để
học nghề này để học lập trình cũng như
mấy ông đang học này thì ở thì thì mình
cái lớp để đưa sẽ gặp Lương không khí Ê
tôi dậy để 35 thì tôi được thăng thăng
chức khá nhiều đứng lên là trưởng bộ môn
nghệ ngoài phết nhưng mà vẫn tôi chẳng
quả được ai là thì
được dậy mấy cái lốp dành cho người lớn
như thế nữa thành ra là
mức lương của tôi hồi đấy lên khi mà
rảnh được cả tuần như thế ở mức lương
lên hơn 300 triệu
anh thưởng tết nhiều nữa nếu mà thấy là
khó bóc lột đó Bởi vì ạ lớp tôi dậy từ
20 sinh viên 22 năm sinh Zalo như một
một sinh viên ở hơn 3 triệu tiền học của
số tiền mình kiếm được
chưa 10 phần trăm số tiền học sinh viên
mình đóng I
à à
khoa
học điện tử sinh sản suy + + tổng hợp
chuyển giới chính xác thực các bạn không
hợp cái gì mấy quan trọng còn nếu mà
không hiểu về lập trình thì thì nó khó
và vì nhảy sang ngôn ngữ nào gặp nhau Nó
cũng không quan trọng hơn nữa đâu
Thôi không chơi coi tôi không chơi chứng
khoán rồi không chơi mấy cái gì đó để
về kinh doanh kinh tế lắm ngày tôi không
Tôi không quan tâm tiền bạc không bị
quan tâm mình phải vấn đề lắm nhớ về sau
tôi sẽ đầu từ tôi sẽ mở quán cà phê của
riêng tôi thì tôi hi vọng đấy vì à Bây
giờ thì ra quán cà phê dành cho dân văn
phòng dân công nghệ để mà ngồi cả ngày
được là hiếm
Ừ đúng ạ Mẹ tôi về sau tôi vẫn mong là
mở được kế quán cafe cho anh em sẽ ngồi
á
khi
đôi cần mua thuốc đau đầu cho cái máy
rửa bán nhà tôi I
Ừ đúng rồi Mình mình nói chuyện mượt một
phần Chắc ở bởi vì mình thường đi dậy
rồi và một phần là mình cũng xem dây vi
tuổi Mai hỗ trợ nhiều xem nhiều video cơ
đến bây giờ vẫn xem có phải xem video
của tôi xem nhiều kênh kiểu nói cái nào
chuyện ổn rồi mà mình tham khảo mà
à à
có khả tiếng Anh khi đi xin thực tập có
điều lương được không Cái này vừa và
cũng có thể nếu mà ông xin vào công ti
nước ngoài còn công ty Việt Nam Thực ra
nó ít công ty để ý lắm trừ khi công ty
liên doanh sang nước ngoài hay kẹo làm
đối tác nước ngoài nhiều thì chả còn
được là ít à
Ừ ông có bằng cấp gì Thì đó rồi là không
quan trọng lắm bởi vì chị bây giờ gần
như là lập trình viên nào cũng cần đến
biết đọc tài liệu nổi tiếng Anh chị ơi
yêu cầu tối thiểu rồi chứ không phải là
yêu cầu ông phải nói được tiếng Anh hay
gì đó Nói tiếng Anh là đấy Khi ông cần
giao tiếp ngoài nhưng mà nhưng mà rõ
ràng là lập trình viên mình thì giao
tiếp ít lắm ạ
cho tôi vậy tôi nghĩ việc và mình cốt để
năm bao nhiêu tuổi thì ra tôi không nghĩ
việc chắc chắn là tôi sẽ không làm lập
trình viên để năm 30 tuổi
à theo kiểu là đi làm ở công ty khác năm
30 tuổi sẽ không tôi tôi sẽ kiểu ở
đấy tôi định năm bao nhiêutuổi đâu mở
quán cà phê mà mày không đợi 45 năm nữa
ra ủng hộ nhé niềm nhớ con không thì tôi
ở tôi sẽ làm giảng viên ta vẫn sẽ có cốt
nhưng mà cốt không phải ở không chạy
được treo mày em về nữa Bộ là mình nhảy
lên là leader hay cái gì đó
Lên làm để mà giảng viên hoặc là kiểu
diễn giả gì đó chứ không không ngồi cây
cây như thế này mãi được đồng ngoại với
nó đau đầu và cũng không theo được công
nghệ thay đổi nhằm nhiều để học
anh
làm sao để được giữ lại ở trường Dậy á Ở
trường cũ của tôi ở Giữ lại để chiều Ngủ
dậy rồi vì một phần là do cũng có ít
người
để cũng đã bị yếu tố thứ hai là ông phải
cái hồi đấy tụi tôi được để ý là bởi vì
tôi thường đi kèm các bạn ở trong lớp
nữa thầy Thôi nhìn thấy cái túi chất
việc tao tối thì kèm được các bạn khác
như thế thì lại một cách việc và bạn
không Không những bạn
lắm mọi thứ đều ổn các bạn mới có tư duy
cũng khá là mở nữa Mình nghĩ nên là như
thế không nên tư duy của bọn cụ quá
không nên cậu cút dạng kẹo ở hơi hơi cứ
cho rồi sợ nhiều
xã hội bị kiểu à
Ừ cái cứ cho Bảo thụ cũng không Không
chịu đổi mới không chịu tiếng thôi khó
mà làm giáo viên nữa à
khi
mở Hà Nội thôi Mình ở Hà Nội mà
You are a cơ vô cơ thì cái đấy là cái
đam mê Ngoài Luồng thôi chứ chứ không
không kiếm tiền nhiều cái này mà không ạ
Các bạn thở ra về sau đam mê của tôi là
mẫu quán cà phê chưa chắc hả Thôi khi
vọng không kiếm được nhiều từ đấy đâu
Nếu em nói về xong cái nghề được sự để
kiếm tiền thì cho ạ giảng viên này nó cả
diễn ra nghề khác còn cà phê ở đam mê sẽ
có nghĩa là lúc đầu sẽ lỗ này phải tôi
đam mê kiểu gì cũng phải sống chết với
nó
gà trống hỏi tôi về sao đội nghĩa là nó
là kiểu dạng là working bay Nếu mà mày
không tìm hiểu working Space nó sẽ bao
gồm có cả nồi ngủ và có phòng tắm Tao
hứa thứ thì mà ở 2424 được đấy
họ nhân viên xinh à Ừ Tôi chắc chắn là
tôi nghĩ trường hợp đấy nhưng mà thật ra
nơi đấy nơi làm việc của máy cũng trung
tâm mấy ông cơm đến đấy hả toàn nhựa tại
nhân viên của tội này kia hơi bị không
cần em tổ chức làm việc đúng ạ Nhưng mà
chắc À cái à
ừ cái bọn nền bác ra ở cái gì đó Nói cho
cái thiết kế thiết kế xung quanh thì tôi
không chắc là về sau có dính líu đến gái
xinh hay không có hai chơi bao game ấy
không ạ
Có mạng luôn mấy ông bây giờ ông nào mở
đam mê bỏ game
Nói chung thì ở tôi sẽ đăng lên để mặc
Kêu gọi mấy ông đam mê p mấy ông sẽ ra
gia nhập phải làm của tôi Tôi đang rất
thiếu người để chơi chơi bốc lên cùng à
I work thứ ba có vài nơi rồi có vài nơi
cũng mở cái rồi cho tôi không chán nhiều
lắm
vì Quốc à
a working Space
có nhiều đâu tôi biết vài nơi có working
Space tôi chắc chắn tôi sẽ làm sự khác
biệt Tôi khẳng định tôi sẽ có tính khác
biệt một tí xíu nhiều cũng học hỏi một
vài nơi có cái sẽ tham khảo thử cái này
em hỏi chỗ quán cái cách bất à Cũng hay
là thậm chí là tôi đang nghĩ là vì sao
của tôi còn có thể gả sinh viên của tôi
về sau biết vì sao tôi vẫn dậy dậy thêm
mà nó ngọt thì bạn sinh viên tôi ra đấy
tôi Chị đã
thêm thêm khách hiểu ý
cho nó giống kiểu cà phê này cũng có
nhưng mà cái quan trọng là nó không gian
nó thoải mãi không ra nó hơi bị nó sẽ có
cả kín cả Mở để mà các bạn cà phê Bây
giờ các bạn bị mở quá là các bạn sẽ
không tập trung được khi mà các bạn họp
chẳng ai ra cà phê bây giờ hiếm giá cà
phê họp với nó ồn đúng không đấy thì thì
mấy ông cần có nơi để mà làm việc tập
trung thì thật là có ghi Spike rộng có
nhưng mà web Spider nó sẽ bao nhiêu điểm
mà nó thương ấy thuê trong ngày đôi khi
là các bạn Ví dụ ở một một vài ông kiểu
bây giờ ông đang lập trình viên ông kiểu
muốn cuối tuần ra cà phê ở một hai tiếng
thôi thì làm gì có chuyện mà thuê 12
tiếng ngon thì cái chỗ này nó phù hợp
hơn quán cà phê nhưng mà thật là không
bán cho cái cà phê ở bản quan trọng cái
chỗ thì mấy ông ngồi làm việc ông hiểu
không quýu weber có thể hạn sẽ có mấy bu
đấy
à à
a Pot game Oggy là gì ạ boardgame Chứ
không phải là passport là cái bàn đấy
chứ không phải boss game Ball game là
kiểu thể thao boardgame mình các bạn
tiếp xúc nhiều rồi Nó kiểu thận sẽ chơi
tá lả chơi bài nó bắt lên để ngồi chơi
trên bàn Chiều ăn quan hay là cá ngựa nó
bắt lên cờ vua Nó là bắt game nhưng mà
chẳng qua khi mà bây giờ nói khái niệm
Bác lên thì ra là con dream rất nhiều
loại game nữa ở bên ngoài du nhập về đấy
à
ờ ờ tìm hiểu công nghệ khác không Hiện
tại thì được cái mà mình không tìm hiểu
nhiều công nghệ khác lắm Mình biết
chuyên đúng với mình chuyên sâu của VNPT
và cả bên g-suite bây giờ mình tìm hiểu
Nhưng mà về sau thì định hướng của mình
là không hẳn là thêm về sau nếu mà là
công ty công ty cần họ làm cũng đi khác
mà cần thêm ngôn ngữ khác thì cho mình
cũng sẽ tìm hiểu thôi vì thực ra nó cũng
không còn là khó mình tìm hiểu cùng ngôn
ngữ khác bây giờ nhưng mà bây giờ mình
đang hướng sâu lại không phải về ngôn
ngữ mà mình hưởng sâu vì đã ta bây nhiều
hơn b mình Nam thường sau rất nhiều lên
tao bây vì công ty mình khá thân liệu
dõi mà mình cảm thấy nó khá phù hợp với
mình với mình thích cái kiểu
cái việc đó xử lý dữ liệu hơn là việc
ngôn ngữ ngôn ngữ bây giờ đâu có quan
trọng đâu nếu vậy nói ngôn ngữ về không
quan trọng
mà
quan trọng là việc xử lý dữ liệu ở cách
xử lý bài toán để mà nó Nó kiểu hiệu quả
để mà cậu thừa mình không chuyên thuật
toán nhưng mà mình thích mấy cái kiểu
như thế
Ê mày em tiếp viên dạy lập trình nữa
thôi Thế thì mấy ông chắc là mày không
tập trung vào ngồi để mình nói gì đâu
Mấy ông cứ gạ với em đấy da xưa sửa cái
gì được đúng tự tạo mất thì máy em bị
sửa lỗi chết
có
mấy tuần Facebook mua trên diễn đàn tốn
Facebook có nhiều loại mà tôn Facebook
tôi hệ chạy quảng cái tên Facebook thể
chặn chặn ngang một bạn nào đó giống cái
click ha chúng tôi mới có rất nhiều loại
tôn để một vụ mục đích chỉ để mà kiểu để
làm được đi vào nhanh và mình không cần
làm thủ công thôi mà
Anh ở mình đang nghĩ trường hợp mà mình
không đủ không đủ chỗ để mà thuê chắc
chắn phải thuê một cái chỗ khá rộng ở
trong trung tâm thương mại
à à
đi cà phê ngồi lâu khó sinh lời không
Mình sẽ thấy bảo mình kiếm tiền không
phải từ cà phê mà mình sẽ kiếm tiền từ
cái chỗ ngồi cơ nghe được giọng mà ngồi
càng lâu thì sẽ làm tôn Nghĩa là tính
tiền theo giờ giống kiểu nét thôi sẽ
kiếm kiểu thấy nó Cafe net đây
53 chưa có kinh nghiệm thì phỏng vấn khó
không cái thứ mình từng nói qua về một
trong các lý do nó về phỏng vấn thôi chả
các bạn có vài bạn hãy trả đang mới này
chắc các bạn hãy xem mẹ hết đi theo từ
đâu hoặc cà phê sau chắc là mình rảnh
mình sẽ phải cắt Dần người video mình
thành những cái sót ngắn để các bạn xem
cho nhanh là có tiêu đề nó đỡ thì các
bạn sẽ xem lại nữa Thế ở mình không nhớ
rồi nó nằm ở đâu ạ
Ừ đúng rồi đủ tiền đi chị em Mai rồi Vậy
sao tôi phải cần có một ông có tư vấn
hơn tôi với khoản kinh tế kém kinh doanh
không Mình gọi dẫn kinh doanh đâu
Khi nào rare rồi còn nhiều việc không
bây giờ nào về còn nhiều cực vừa công ty
rồi tuyển rất nhiều về
tuyển về TP và bây giờ phải đến 70 80
phần trăm là phải là với em với nó vương
quốc gia khác khả năng kiểu Được hỗ trợ
nhiều
Chị Thơ Thơ
à à
xe
tăng cốt bằng tiếng Việt thôi đừng nhốt
bằng tiếng Việt ông điên à
tiếng Việt về phức tạp kết hợp việc à
Không ai dụng máy đến nhiều đâu đừng có
cốt ạ
em không đi thực tập các bạn nếu mà các
bạn làm về quét các bạn không nên nên
cốt nhiều hơn hơn mà kéo thả web
anh ạ
kỹ thuật toán không tốt thì có ảnh hưởng
không Mình có biết gì về thuật toán đâu
nhưng mà có ảnh hưởng gì không nhưng mà
về sau các bạn đúng là các bạn về sau
mỗi năm trình lên thì đương nhiên các
bạn phải biết lý thuyết và cấp tối ưu
các thứ thì có thể thuật toán này đã tao
bây này
cái gì nhỉ Ở tự nhiên phân tích hệ thống
vẫn nên cảm biến càng thêm tiền thôi à
à à
thì các bạn thật ra không cần để biết
nhiều ngôn ngữ người kia thể kiếm được
việc đâu các bạn chỉ cần nên chuyên một
ngôn ngữ ở đó là em hoàn toàn này kiếm
được rồi nếu mà các bạn khoe biết nhiều
ngôn ngữ quá thì người ta lại càng càng
nghĩ là các bạn kiểu mỗi thứ biết Mỹ
không biết được chuyên sâu một cái gì
không tốt
hả Model rồi không làm được án mới thế
quá sai quá sai luôn bây giờ nó lại
Facebook Quốc vẫn còn đang xịn và đang
mới thành ra kìa không khả năng mới đang
vẫn năng và phát triển nên vẫn đang rất
nhiều
công ty mới vẫn đang làm gì
ở đồng hồ web bây giờ có thể cốt 2 cửa
môđun Nhưng mà thực ra cốc web mà về các
bạn nó vỡ là nó vào nó phù hợp với kiểu
là làm còn mì ăn liền chứ không phải ở
Word và phù hợp làm theo cổ là
kiểu làm trang web miễn liền hơn hơn là
làm chuyên sâu hạt một cái một cái trang
web kiểu dạng là một cái sản phẩm Dulux
đấy hợp làm áo thuộc làm một cái gì bỏ
ngang gỗ ra sự đó thuê Bạn làm nhanh
trong vòng 12 tuần để làm cái trang web
chỉ cho 56 triệu 20 triệu thì các bạn
làm cái đánh nhanh mà web Còn nếu mà giờ
có bảo làm hoàn trang web 100 triệu đến
tỉ thì chẳng ai làm cốt quét cả web nó
rất là nặng nó tích hợp quá nhiều các
bạn mình cốt trai sẽ ổn hơn
Ừ đúng rồi web bán hàng hay mày web tin
tức kiểu kiểu kiểu dạng hóa kiểu nó chỉ
cần nằm ngang chỉ cần đủ để xài thôi thì
chị quét là xong là quá hoàn hảo rồi vì
nó quá tiện nhanh chẳng cần chẳng cần
phải học luôn cũng kéo thả làm được xong
nhưng mà tôi không hiểu mấy ông như thế
đấy không phải lập trình đối tôi đấy
không phải là chính
thì nó vẫn là kéo thả mà ai chẳng làm
được
vụ án mạng mà dù trời cho mấy ông tìm
hiểu rồi cái đấy trước rồi mấy ông
thường là hồi trước tôi học ở trường tôi
được tìm hiểu cái đấy trước thì mày ông
hình dung được web nó hoạt động như nào
sau đó vợ tôi học cốt rồi bọn tôi mới
thấy Cốt nó tiện hơn như thế nào ạ
Anh
ở chuồng có dạy không không quan trọng
em ạ Em vẫn chủ yếu là học lập trình này
vẫn phải tự học chứ bởi vậy trường dạy
mà Trường dậy nóng chỉ dậy mức cơ bản
thôi Chủ yếu mình vẫn tự học hết và lẫn
cả là trường mà còn dậy làm cho em mất
cảm hứng nữa thì cắn chết nữa đừng có
đừng các bạn lên đại học các bạn đừng
phụ thuộc vào trường trường dạy cái gì
mình học đấy nó khác với thời cầm tay
chỉ lỗi không ngờ thời có 1 cấp 2 áp trừ
khi các bạn học trường nghề Giống như
mình dùng dậy thì nó mới đúng nghĩa khái
niệm cầm tay chỉ lỗi mà con giỗ dẫn
nhiều hơn dậy rồi thế để mà truyền được
cảm hứng cho các bạn theo cái ngành này
còn con à
công việc mà học lập trình mà các bạn bị
phụ thuộc vào trường em trường em dạy ra
pha nên em biết mỗi ra thôi thế là quá
giờ đúng ạ Không không Bơ nói câu đấy
khi đi phỏng vấn nhé
Ok mình xin phép
anh
chia sẻ Note có một cái à thêm cái này
năm vipo các bạn nên có thể tham khảo
này dụng là cái này đến dạy qua với GS
này thả ổ này nhớ lớn nhưng tạo một mình
anh nhé À như Đô node.js này nghe tên
nói lên tất cả mọi cái này là
sách miễn phí để học lập trình này không
biết có nhiều hay không nhưng mã chồng
vẻ xem qua này có vẻ được nhiều nhiều
đánh giá tích cực cái
topic ATI rồi kệ api là để làm gì để mà
kiểu các bạn gọi đến để lấy thông tin và
sửa ra các bạn muốn muốn trang web các
bạn cập nhật thời gian thực về tình
trạng Coffee chẳng hạn như sẽ có một cái
bi ai đã từng của ông nào thật mà thống
kê số liệu của ví thì ông chị được em
chỉ cần gọi đến cái kia đấy và em lấy
được về thông tin đấy rồi Em nhìn chị em
trang của em thì cái api nó thể em có
rất nhiều hay với ai về rất nhiều thứ
không phải mỗi cái đấy có thể về thời
tiết hay về mọi thứ luôn thì em đây là
những cái đề chan tổng hợp những cái
công khai đấy để mà hình như là miễn gì
nữa để các bạn đời miễn phí này để bạn
hoàn toàn sử dụng của truyện tranh các
bạn thường liên quan đến tiền tệ thời
tiết là gì Do nữa đôi khi ở có thể vào
diễn viên hay là về phim ảnh về đôi khi
ở Hồi trước ở tôi làm đó là bìa sách nữa
những năm chỉ ở các bạn các bạn Nhập ví
dụ các bạn làm trang web bản à bán sách
này các bạn hay vì các bạn Nhập đầy đủ
thông tin sách rõ ràng nó vô nó nó ghi
hết ở trên quyển sách rồi như các bạn
Nhập tay và không còn chỉ cần nhập mã
của cuốn sách đây với mã mình sắp về là
mã quốc tế rồi mà quy ước cô quốc tế rồi
thì các bạn chỉ cần nhập cái mã vào
trong thẻ ATM này api trả phải toàn bộ
thông tin mua sách cả nội dung cuốn sách
luôn thì các bạn chỉ cần lưu lại trong
BB sao rồi có về sao bạn hình cho người
dùng xem thôi Cái đó là lợi ích của ai
với ai à a tiếp theo ai đi à
chú ý tưởng của đề mà các bạn làm forex
khá ổn Ai tệ đồ ăn hay các bạn thử tham
khảo không ạ
khi inter view cái này phỏng vấn phỏng
vấn cốt ở trường đại học này hay này các
bạn để xem nhé tôi tôi sẽ ra tôi chưa
xem hết Này này đâu tôi khổ đây tôi lưu
lại cho tôi có rất nhiều đã lưu lại
nhưng không thể sẽ lại này thì mấy ông
thể xem nhé á
có nhiều cái mô đun kiểu cốt nhiều và
khó khăn tiền là môđun núm Đúng chắc
chắn là mình không phủ nhận về cái việc
wordpad bây giờ Đông vẫn rất nhiều trang
web vẫn đang dùng bờ biển là thích hợp
nhiều bộ đồ đó làm nhanh vừa Tiện nhưng
mà nó tích hợp quá nhiều thế Ghost về cơ
bản vẫn nặng Nếu là chị hợp cho những
cái trang web mình vẫn nó là mì ăn liền
còn những cái trang lớn rất xa lạ chẳng
ai ôm có vé phải dùng cả Không ạ và Minh
hướng đến các bạn không phải làm cái cậu
mến liền như thế không không hưởng các
bạn cốt để mua đun như thế mà hướng các
bạn làm hàm Đúng rồi trong master đầu
lên cô ấy tự các bạn làm được và rất
nhiều công ty tuyển hơn còn công ty làm
như của dịch vụ để mà làm mì ăn liền thì
mình không cần kĩ nhá 10 các bạn này
mình hướng các bạn làm theo kiểu mẫu lắm
không hướng các bạn làm cái cổ áo xuống
kiểu mì ăn liền à
Ừ đúng rồi tỷ giá ngân hàng nữa cũng qua
đi bia này kiểu tiền tệ các thử nữa
Ờ Ờ Bây giờ mình xin phép mà
tâm sự nốt có một cái tâm sự nốt thôi
hôm nay vườn hai tiếng thôi Ờ
có xem cái video ngoài nhưng chắc à bây
giờ khá hay này đây giờ rồi mình nói
luôn nên mình không cho các bạn xem cảm
thấy cái gieo hai cái bạn như phút này
đâu Mình mình sẽ không nói ra cũng chưa
tự nhiên mình tình cờ mình mình vừa nãy
mình có nói qua là mình lười nên mình
định mua cái máy rồi bác mà mình gặp Tìm
máy rửa bát ở trên chị thuốc thôi đương
nhiên tự nhẹ để sau này còn bị này đi
đây không nhắc ngày máy rửa bát cơ Cái
video của chị này mình từng xem video để
video thứ hai mình từng xem mình nếu mà
các bạn biết rồi mình không phải là con
người thích tiếp theo thấy có ai nổi
tiếng mì theo dõi và mình xem giống như
ạ ảnh Đội C mình cũng nghĩ Tí xem à Hai
Bầu cái ra mà rất nhiều người nữa mình
chẳng biết nữa rất nhiều người từng nói
mình nói giống ai đó thì hãy kiểu anh
biết người này không chẳng biết gì cả
Tôi không cho tôi tôi không hướng đến
cái đấy nhưng mà
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà chị này
không phải tôi nói chị này hay Nhưng mà
tôi đang nói được à cái ra có vài video
tí nha cái video này tôi thấy hội và cái
video trước nỡ của tôi xem về cái máy
mài dọn c** mày dọn phân cho cho mèo 20
củ mình đô nhưng mà cũng khá hay
cái hay ở đây đó là cái cách nói chuyện
thôi Đương nhiên Đương nhiên là ờ
số tự nhiên à Đây là cách làm chuyện
người giàu nữa nếu mà cái cách nói
chuyện và cách suy nghĩ của chị này tôi
thấy ạ khá ổn cái tư duy chắc là cũng là
để cũng là để chiều lòng người xem đến
khá là ổn chữ con à
em còn tôi không biết được người ra
ngoài đời như thế nào không biết người
ta đã phốt chuyện cái gì tôi không quan
tâm thôi không quan tâm nữa điều đấy mà
tôi không Tôi không hướng đến mấy ông
xem những cái tất cả video của chị này
Anh vừa nói cái video cho thấy hay bởi
vì nó nói qua với nội thất với thích nội
thất Nhưng nói thật là cách chị có vẻ là
chị tư duy để bố trí các nội thất đẩy
tôi thấy sẹo cái còn những video khác
tôi chưa xem nên tôi chưa anh ra được
ở nhà tôi thấy video mà mày không để xem
này không sẽ suy nghĩ lại việc này Các
nội thất cho thử và cái hay thì tôi
hướng đến nữa đó là nếu không có thể bắt
chị này Giàu nó chỉ là như thế còn em
đưa em nghèo em xem cái này làm gì em để
có tiền để làm cái này Vâng ví dụ điển
hình có đầu ghi sáu này chị chuẩn bị
giới thiệu ta thử nghe nhé
Nếu mẹ xem video này có sữa mẹ
Tại sao Xin Lỗi Mẹ gửi cái cái lò vi
sóng của chị em mua là 22 triệu đấy Kiểu
một cái lò vi sóng đấy thịt tôi không
kiên mình mình sẽ trả lời Không kêu làm
gì hết nhưng mà Ừ cái cái việc ở 13
không phải người ta thành công như thế
nào mấy ông Nhữ Học tập mà cái việc là
người ta kiểu như nào như nào đấy
Ê mấy ông hãy cố phấn đấu để mà sao cho
kiếm Nếu không quen nhìn những cái tiêu
cực à tự ăn những cái tích cực thì ông
sẽ kiểu thích dần lên đấy Chúc mấy ông
cứ kiểu bi quan lúc nào cũng nghĩ việc
cả mấy cái nghĩ được tâm nhìn ngắn các
thứ mà ông sẽ làm những cái rĩa ngắn Nếu
hiểu gì đâu mạnh nếu vậy luôn nhìn thấy
tươi sáng tôi thường anh xem những cái
tươi sáng thì tôi nghĩa là cuộc sống
tích cực hơn và tôi sẽ cũ phấn đấu cố
phấn đấu này được những cái đấy i
Ừ đúng rồi xem review nhà thấy các tiểu
sử cũng có mà để trợ cái uống gì đấy
trông chứa những cái những cái kiểu dạng
làm mấy ông thì đam mê mà không thích bé
ngồi hướng đến những cái đấy hướng đến
chứ không phải xem cho vui không nhá xem
chỉ cho vui xong rồi vẫn về sau bữa ăn
mì tôm ngồi xem tiếp chứ Thì cuộc sống
của mấy ông vẫn giữ lại chỗ quá lắm Bọn
mày không phải đi lên
a a a
thể loại đua gà cái gì tôi có cứ gạ mày
không đi Bitcoin đâu mà đùi gà à
anh khác
à à
ở nhà to Nói chung có nhiều cái hay lắm
mày Ông này ông chắc là nó phải không
biết nhiều cây rồi tôi sẽ đang đề xuất
một cái cái cách nói chuyện gì đấy Tôi
thể khó ổi là để mà thăm tham khảo thôi
thư tư duy thì nhiều người có tư duy
khác nhau ví dụ của chị người ăn chay
tôi không phải người em trai tôi sẽ khó
chịu Ai ăn chay ạ
đây nhờ mỗi thứ tư duy khác nhau mà ạ
ờ ờ
à à
a tiếp theo là mình tâm sự nốt cái này
nhanh trong vòng 3 phút à
anh giống như vừa nãy có bạn bảo là bao
giờ anh à 30 tuổi anh nhỉ cốt hoặc là
cái sau
anh về sau cậu không không
anh không đi làm nữa vân vân thì
cho tôi đã nhớ lại hồi mà tôi được về
quê rồi Tết để mà đồng vui chơi rồi đấy
cảm thấy cả mọi thứ rất thoải mái nhẹ
nhõm kiểu thanhbinh kiểu đến cả sau Tết
tôi vẫn chẳng thể tập trung làm việc
được rồi đấy cũng nhận này
Ừ cái thanhbình xung quanh về tôi tôi là
dân Hà Nội kiểu nào phá xô bồ sinh sống
ở xã xô bồ
thì
tôi lại quen kiểu Hà Nội hơn tướng ngờ
vẫn thích cái cảm giác Thanh Bình kia
chắc chắn có rồi nhưng mà chắc là tôi
nghĩa tuổi trẻ mình lên 3 chạm xô bồ thì
như thế ở và khi mà đến cho bọn về già
về hưu cho tôi sẽ về quê cho thanhbình
cảnh như thế thận thường chứ trừ khi mà
đang trẻ nhưng tôi về đấy thì tôi không
thể làm được việc đấy Kiểu đang trong
tâm trạng với ở lưng thoải mái không thì
trong lành vui vẻ các thứ không làm được
việc gì cả
anh không biết mày không có như thế
không không biết mấy ông kiểu dạng là
trong kiểu khi mà xung quanh đều kiểu
bận rộn thì tôi sẽ bận rộn được theo
kiểu kiểu thế xung quanh mà gọn Thanh
Bình quá kiểu ai cũng chơi cậu ai cũng
cậu không lo lắm lo toan rồi cả thì mình
cũng bị nạn theo ý
chị
sẽ hồi mà tôi về quê để tôi để đánh lắm
đấy hả thanhbình Chẳng biết vì sao nào
đâu rồi nãy tôi đang nghĩ nếu mà nếu mà
không có gì thay đổi nếu mà về sau vẫn
như thế thì chắc là bà Nẵng là một lời
khá Đừng tưởng dân Đà Nẵng thiện thân
luyện thân thiện phết
Ê bà Cuộc sống này chẳng có gì tấp nập
cả Hồi đấy tôi về hết kiểu 9 giờ tắt đèn
không ạ Tắt đèn đi ngủ ở đây không có
khái niệm đấy 9 giờ phải đi bắt đầu lên
39 thật đẹp mà không đèn vẫn có người
bao toát hết cửa hàng thôi à
em mình hơi bị tâm hồn hơi bị cụ non một
tí mình là giảng viên à thế này nhá
không thừa mình là như thế cũng nên bởi
lên làm giảm viêm à à
em
có bạn vào mình làm video review à xem
khi nào mình sẽ vì một cái ghi đó Những
cái đồ Thế mà vẫn gợi ý vài đồ mà Tôi
thấy có vẻ
ổn để cho mấy ông dùng nhưng mà không
không hướng đến ở một cái video review
đồ đâu và tội không được ăn tiền quảng
cáo cũng trạng hư cố hướng đến hiểu nó
giống như ăn thì gặp như ý
à à
nhà hả Ừ
ừ ừ
Em 25 tuổi giảng viên lập trình viên
Lương 1x Thành Công
anh không không không không không không
phải nói như này ạ 22 tuổi trưởng bộ môn
lập trình lương bãi Khối đấy tôi được
như thế đấy mới gọi là thành công
rồi con nhà người ta luôn rồi còn bây
giờ tôi tôi đang chụp hình trái ý
Em 22 tuổi nhá đây làm trưởng bộ môn này
nhé nghe phát biểu
nhưng mà rõ ràng tôi bảo chuyện buồn nói
của anh nghe rồi dễ dàng
rồi đấy còn ít người đó dưới mình giữa
hai người
Ừ Rồi sau đó thì khi mà tôi đang trên
trên bờ vực thành công như thế mà tôi
nhỉ nhiều người cho rằng anh sẽ nói địa
hình mẹ tôi đã nhưng mà tôi không có tâm
gì đấy bởi vì tôi trẻ mà từ nên là phải
có phải cậu Phấn đấu phải cỗ ra ngoài va
chạm chứ không thể dẫn chân tại chỗ nơi
như thế
ờ ờ
Ừ thôi bây giờ hơn hai tiếng rồi chắc là
cũng
cũng kết thúc thôi ông ạ không Dài quá
mấy ông sao không dám xem đâu Tạm kết hộ
đây Có gì buổi sau lại mình lại kiểm tra
tiếp là tâm sự tiếp sau có ông hoàng Nếu
cứ bình luận rồi tôi tôi buổi trước tôi
còn chưa tổng hợp video trả lời câu hỏi
cho buổi sau đó tổng hợp rồi trả lời hết
một luôn một lượt nhé Thôi tạm cho bạn
nhé
em chỉ thôi à